you're about to learn how to program in
Java from Farhan hassin children Farhan
is an experienced software developer
here at free code camp and he is great
at breaking down concepts for beginners
this is a great course if you want to
learn Java and you can follow along with
the whole course from within your web
browser Farhan will teach you the basics
of java using replit replit is an online
IDE that allows people to write all
sorts of programming languages right
within their web browser and repl
provided a grant that made this course
possible so it's time to learn Java
hello everyone welcome to the Java for
beginners course I am Farhan Hassan
chodri and in this course I will teach
you all the fundamental concepts around
Java now ideally a programming course
usually starts by downloading and
installing a lot of sdks or Ides or
whatnot but since we will be using
rapidly throughout the entire course we
don't need to do any of those replete is
an online collaborative IDE that you can
use right from your browser to start go
to
www.reply.com and you should land on the
page you can create an account on
replete or if you already have an
account just go ahead and log into that
I will just use my Google account to log
in once you have logged in you will land
on your home page from here you can
create a new Ripple by using this create
button
now from the list of language we will
pick Java but just so that you know
refleet supports a long list of
languages make sure you are giving your
new Rebels some descriptive names such
as hello world
finally hit the create triple button and
wait until the process finishes
now if you have worked with some other
code editors such as Visual Studio code
the look of replete should not be very
different to you you can change its
default layout by going to settings
and default layout by default it should
be side by side
but you can also pick stacked if you
like that layout Now the default Java
Ripple usually comes with a bunch of
code and you may have already guessed
that this is the famous hello world
program written in Jaffa to run this
code click on this run button here
and you will see the code's output on
the console
there you go congratulations on creating
and running your first Rebel on the next
lesson I will explain what's going on
just before we leave
remember you can always run replay dark
by clicking on this Moon icon and if you
prefer dark themes over the lighter ones
please go ahead
the hello world program is probably the
simplest executable Java program that
you can write yet it's very important
that you understand each part of this
program
as you may have already guessed source
files in Java end with the dot Java
extension and compiled byte codes
usually end with the dot class extension
to see the compiled byte codes on replay
click on these three dots on the files
menu and click on show hidden files
the program starts with a class
declaration a class is a collection of
related code in Java in every Java
source file that is the file with the
dot Java extension you can have one top
level public class and that class has to
match the name of the source file this
is because if you have multiple classes
in your program like this
you will see that the Java compiler
produces individual byte cores for each
class
to avoid any confusion about which of
these classes is the entry point to the
program the jvm is designed to treat the
bytecode that matches the name of the
source file as the entry point
inside the class there is a main method
those of you familiar with C C plus plus
or go may already know that the main
method or function serves as the NG
point to your program
the jvm is programmed in a way that it
will specifically look for a static
method that is named main has Public
Access takes an array of string as a
parameter and doesn't return any value
so you will have to write your main
method as public static void main string
arcs and nothing else
one thing that you can change however is
the name of the args array
to something like
arguments
the array holds the command line
arguments passed to the program upon
execution
the
system.out.print element method prints
out whatever string you pass to it as an
argument unlike python or JavaScript
semicolons are mandatory in Java so if
you leave it out the program will fail
to compile
that's pretty much it about the hello
world program don't worry if you didn't
understand all the terms used in this
lesson you will have a much better idea
about topics like public and private
access modifiers Statics classes methods
in later lessons
now if you try to run the program using
the Run button
everything works out just as expected
another thing that you can change is the
entry point
this will make sure that replit opens
the correct Java source file whenever
you decide to return to this project
now there are a lot of other options in
this dot replete file but those are not
important right now
the hello world program you have been
seeing so far is pretty simple if you
want to write more complex programs you
will at least need some understanding of
the different types of data and
variables variable is any entity that
can take on different values for example
if you want to store your age inside a
variable you can do so like this
first you will have to write the type of
the variable age is an integer or int
then you will have to write the name of
the variable which is age in this case
then you can finish off by putting a
semicolon
you just declared a variable declaring
means the compiler will know that this
variable exists however you will also
need to Define it you can do so by
assigning a value to this variable like
this
write the name of the variable then an
equal sign followed by your desired
value
in this case the equal sign is known as
an assignment operator we'll learn about
operator in lot more detail in lateral
lessons now you can print out the
variable to the console like this
and just in case you are wondering using
a plus sign is one of the many ways to
print out a dynamic value in between
sentences
keep in mind you cannot use an
uninitialized variable in Java so if you
remove this line
and try to run the code
the code will fail with the error
message variable age might not have been
initialized
instead of declaring and initializing
the variable in different lines you can
do it in one go like this
on the line of Declaration
after the name of the variable put an
assignment operator followed by your
desired value
now if you try to run the code again
see everything's back to normal
you can change the value of a variable
as many times as you want so if you set
the value of the age variable to 28
instead of 27 just before printing it
out you will see that the value has
changed in the output
although you can assign new values to
the variable multiple times you cannot
declare the same variable twice so if
you do something like this
and try to run the code the code will
fail
with the error message variable age is
already defined in method Main
if you look closely you will see two
different sets of curly braces in this
code the first set marks the start and
end of the hello world class the second
set is inside the class and marks the
start and end of the main method
code inside a set of curly braces is
known as a code block
since the main method is inside the
hello world class any variable you
declare inside the method will be only
available inside the method
these are local variables however you
can also declare variables outside the
method like here in the hello world
class code block
if you do that the variable will be
available within the entire class to use
this variable inside the main method you
will have to declare it as a static
we will discuss the reason behind this
in a later lesson for now just remember
that is static method can only work with
static variables
moving out the Declaration of the age
variable and marking it as a static has
not made any difference whatsoever but
if you remove the value of the variable
and attempt to rerun the program
you will see the program runs without
any issues this time and prints out 0 as
the value of age
this is because whenever you declare a
variable in the class level the Java
compiler will assign a default value to
it for numbers it's always zero now
another thing that I'd like to show you
is
if you redeclare the age variable inside
the main method now
there will be no problem whatsoever
because the initial Declaration of the
age variable is not local to the main
method
so as long as you do not re-declare a
variable within the same code block you
will be good to go
when it comes to naming your variables
you can name them anything as long as
the names don't start with a number and
don't have any spaces in them there are
also around 50 words reserved by Java
itself as keywords and you cannot use
any of them either you can start a
variable name with a dollar sign or an
underscore but excessive usage of these
signs can make your code unreadable in
case of multi-word names always follow
camel casing when naming your variables
if you want to learn about different
programming naming conventions I leave
the link to this article in the
description finally avoid naming your
variables using single letters
now that you know about variables we
will discuss the different types of data
keep in mind I have reorganized the
source file to better reflect what I
will be talking about at a high level
there are two types of data in Java
there are the Primitive types and the
non-primitive or reference types
primitive types store values for example
int is a primitive type and it stores an
integer value a reference type on the
other hand stores the reference to a
memory location where a dynamic object
is being stored we will discuss
reference types later
there are eight primitive data types in
Java six out of those eight types deals
with different types of numbers first
there are the bytes these are small
numbers within the range of -128 to 127.
then there are the shorts with a much
larger range than bytes and the integers
with an even larger range if you ever
need to store a value so large that it
doesn't fit in an INT you can use the
long type by default any number with no
decimal point is treated as an integer
by the compiler to let the compiler know
that a number is actually a long you
have to append the letter L at the end
of the number you can also use a small l
in instead of the capital L if you want
for numbers with decimal points in them
there are double and Float types doubles
are double Precision 64-bit floating
Point numbers with a very long range
floats on the other hand are single
position 32-bit floating Point numbers
with a smaller range by default any
number with a decimal point is treated
as a double by the compiler to let the
compiler know that a number is actually
a float you have to append the letter if
at the end of the number like the lungs
you can use a small If instead of the
Capital One here
Boolean data type can have only two
values true or false at the moment usage
of a data type that can only hold true
or false as values may not seem that
useful to you but once you learn about
conditional statements you will see
their usefulness
finally the character type can hold any
valid Unicode character the Unicode is
kept sequence for the copyright symbol
is backslash u00 A9 so if you store this
value in a car variable and print it out
on the console like this we have
you will see
that the copyright symbol has been
printed on the console instead of the
value we have saved of course you can
also save any standard character from
your keyboard instead of this kind of
Unicode subsequences for example if we
remove the name Copyright symbol and
change it to something like percent
symbol
and replace these Unicode Escape
character with the percent sign
and update our code accordingly
you will see
the percentage symbol printed out on
Console instead of the copyright symbol
there you go
now for the most part when working with
integers
the in-type should suffice and for
numbers with decimal points the double
type should suffice but you should also
know about the other types
although you cannot store one type of
data inside another type of variable
conversion between the different types
is absolutely possible type conversion
in Java can be either implicit or
explicit when the compiler converts a
smaller type of data
for example an integer to a larger one
like a double automatically it's known
as an implicit or narrowing type
conversion
let's see an example
first get rid of all the old code in our
project
then Begin by declaring a new integer
you can call call it anything
then declare a double
and for the value of the double type
assign number one like this
is essentially doing is first taking an
integer with a value of Phi and then
taking a double and assigning number one
as its value
let's try to print it out using the
standard
system.out.print Ln function
number two
and run
so as you can see the compiler has
successfully converted the integer to a
double
this is because a w is larger than an
integer but what will happen if you try
to do the reverse let's try out
this time start with a double
5.8 Maybe
then an INT
okay I missed the two here
now
system.out.print Ln
number two
and drop
so as you can see
the program immediately fails saying
incompatible types possible lossy
conversion from double to in
what the compiler is saying that an
integer to double con conversion is not
possible automatically although
conversion from an in to a double is not
possible automatically you can still do
it explicitly by letting the compiler
know that you want this to happen
the cast operator can be of help here
first inside a set of parentheses right
end this will tell the compiler that you
want to convert this double to an it
let's try to run the program once again
and this time the program works without
any issues but you have lost the point
eight part after 5. if you are doing
explicit type conversion in Java be
extremely careful whether the type you
are converting to will be able to hold
the entire value or not in this case I
knew that an integer will never be able
to hold the entire 5.8 value and I will
lose the second part but I went with it
anyway
so as long as you know what you are
doing you should be all right but at any
given moment if you perform an explicit
conversion and lose a bit of data
accidentally the results can be
catastrophic now that you know about
variables and the different types of
data you can work with in Java you will
have to learn about operators keep in
mind I have made some changes to our
code to better explain our topic in hand
and since our code has become much
longer than before I suggest that you go
to settings
and change the default layout from
stacked to side by side and then hit the
reset layout button to apply the new
layout
this will give you a lot of vertical
space and make the code easier to read
operators in Java or programming in
general are certain symbols that tell
the compiler to perform certain
operations such as arithmetic relational
or logical operations although there are
six types of operators in Java I will
only discuss four bitwise operator are a
little bit more complex than the other
ones and I don't think they fit well in
a beginner's course like this we will
begin our discussion with arithmetic
operators arithmetic operators are the
ones that you can use to perform
arithmetic operations such as addition
subtraction multiplication or division
or so on there are five arithmetic
operators in Java and these are the
addition operator the subtraction
operator the multiplication operator the
division operator and the remainder
operator the remainder operator is also
known as modulo or modulus operator
addition subtraction multiplication and
division these four are pretty
self-explanatory you can have a look at
our code example here
and you should be able to understand
what they do and how they do it if you
have used a calculator in real life the
arithmetic operators in programming work
similarly in our code we have two
integer numbers number one and number
two with the values 12 and 6
respectively so if you add number one
and number two together the result will
be 18. if you subtract number two from
number one the result will be six if you
multiply number one with number two the
result will be 72 and finally if you
divide number one by number two the
result will be two we will talk about
the remainder or modulo operator later
the addition and multiplication
operations in this code are pretty
simple but the subtraction and division
operation needs some more discussion so
we'll get rid of our addition
and multiplication code here
we'll comment out the division code
and the remainder code and focus solely
on the subtraction part as you can see
the value of number one is 12 and number
two is six which means the number one is
greater than number two
as a result the result of the
subtraction operator comes out as
positive but if we change the order of
the operation here so if we make number
two the first operand and number one the
second operand
you will see
that the result of the operation changes
from 6 to -6 again if you have used
calculator cngl live before you should
already be aware of this situation
now the division operation since
dividing 12 by 6 yields the result 2
this operation is perfectly fine but if
we change 6 with something like
maybe five
then the result will not be a whole
number as you can see according to this
program the result will be 2 but if we
perform the same operation in a
calculator or by hand we will know that
the result of this operation should have
been 2.4 now this happens because if you
divide an integer with another integer
the result will always be an integer so
let's try by changing this integer type
to a double
for both operands
and run the program once again
as you can see this time the result is
2.4 but what happens if we divide a
double by an integer
again the result is 2.4 and if we change
the first operand to an end and the
second to a double the result will still
be 2.4 which means if you divide an
integer by another integer the result
will always be an integer but if you
divide a double or float by an integer
or divide an integer by a double or
float the result will always be another
double
now let's get rid of our division code
as well and focus solely on the
remainder or the modulus operation
now for this example I would like to go
back to our original verus which are 12
and 6 in the beginning
and I'd like to go back to integer
let's run the program and see what is
the output
compiling a program may take some time
but we just need to be patient here
so as you can see the result of this
operation is zero
first we need to understand what is a
remainder now you may or may not already
know that a reminder is the value that
remains after you have divided a number
with another one so if you divide 12 by
6 the result will be 2 and there will be
nothing left you can always divide a 12
into two sixes
but if I change 6 to something like
maybe
um
eight
and run the program once again
as you can see the value has changed
from 0 to 4 this is because if you try
to divide 12 by 8 there will always be 4
left I hope you got the idea
you have already seen examples of the
assignment operators in previous lessons
it's pretty simple you can use the equal
sign to assign a value to any variable
in your code but you can also combine
the assignment operator with the five
arithmetic operators you just learned
about
for example
here we have a integer with a value of
12. now if I tell you that you will have
to add 5 with this value and Save in the
same variable
you can do that like this
[Music]
now the output of number should be 17
instead of 12.
very simple but instead of doing this in
such a verbose manner you can do it far
more easily
let's just remove the second part here
and instead of using the assignment
operator use a plus sign
then the assignment operator and then
five
this small line of code is actually
equivalent to number equals number
plus pi
let's comment this out and see if this
gives the same result as before or not
okay
yeah 70.
so you can use all the five arithmetic
operators similarly say for example if
you want to take out 6 from 12 you can
do so by saying number minus equals 6.
and this will turn the value of number
from 12 to 6.
there you can also do modulus operation
like this like if you say
modulus equals and then
2
the result of this operation is 0
because when you divide 12 by 2 there
will be 2 6s as a result and
nothing left I hope you got the idea of
using assignment operator with all the
five arithmetic operators and I would
suggest that you try out usage of the
other ones like the multiplication sign
and the division sign with the
assignment Operator by yourself and see
how the result varies from time to time
so far in this course you have learned
about the arithmetic operators and the
assignment operators the arithmetic
operators usually lets you perform
different types of arithmetic operations
on your numbers and the assignment
operator usually lets you assign
different kinds of value to variables
relational operators on the other hand
usually check the relation among
multiple operands by relation what I
mean is for example in this code we have
two integer numbers number one and
number two with the values 12 and 15
respectively now you may want to know
whether number one or number two is
equal to each other or maybe number one
is greater than number two or maybe
number one is less than number two or
not these are the relation between these
two numbers
so in Java
there are six types of relational
operators the first one is the equality
operator
now keep in mind each relational
operator in Java or in other programming
languages as well usually returns true
or false as a result of an operation for
example on line 7 I have written
system.out.printellent number one equals
equals number two the usage of this
double equal sign here is the equality
operator now if I run the code
since the value of number 1 and number 2
is not equal the output will be false
which is correct in this case now you
may also want to check whether number
one is different from number two or not
for that you can use the not equal to
operator instead of putting two equal
signs side by side you will have to put
an exclamation sign followed by an equal
sign
now if I run the code again you will see
that the second operation gives us a
true
because indeed number one is not equal
to number two
then you can also use the greater than
operator to check whether number one is
greater than number two or not since 12
is smaller than 15 the output of this
line will be false
there you go there is also the opposite
of the greater than operator which is
the less than operator and this
operation in this case will give us true
because number one is actually smaller
than number two
finally there are the greater than or
equal operators
and
the less than or equal operator now the
greater than or equal operator will give
us true only if number one is greater
than number 2 or equal to number two the
less than or equal to operator on the
other hand will give us true only and
only if number one is less than number
two or equals to number two
since number one is actually less than
number two the greater than or equal
operation will give us false and the
less than or equal operation will give
us the result true now the usage of
these relational operators may not seem
uh that much fun to you at the moment
but once you start working with things
like relational statements you will
start to understand how important these
operators are The Logical operators in
Java or in programming in general lets
you make logical decision based on
multiple conditions for example imagine
you are writing a program that can only
be used by people within the age limit
of 18 years old to 40 years old here we
have an integer number with a value of
25. now we will have to make two checks
first we will have to check whether age
is greater than or equal to 18 or not
and then we will have to check whether
age is less than or equal to 40 or not
so you have already learned about the
greater than or equal and less than or
equal operators in the previous lesson
here I will teach you how you can
combine these two operators using a
logical and operator to make a connected
decision okay so let's write system dot
out dot print Ln because we want to
print out the result of our operation
here
and start with the graded then or equal
operation age is greater than or equal
18
then you will have to put double M
person sign and this is the logical and
operator in Java
and then
age is less than or equal to 40.
let's run the code and see what the
output is
as you can see the output is true here
let me explain the logical and operator
in Java or in other programming
languages as well works
in this way if the left side of the
logical and operator and the right side
of the logical and operator yields true
as a result then the whole operation
will give the result true
here the value of age is 25 which is
larger than 18 which means the left side
is true
and it's also less than 40 which means
the right side is also true that's why
the result of this end operation will be
true
but if you change this value to maybe
something like 45 which is clearly over
40 years old and run the program once
again
you will see that the output becomes
false because
although the left side is true the right
side is not
so in case of a logical and operator
both side of the operator has to be true
I apart from The Logical and operator
there is also a logical or operator okay
let's imagine another scenario
maybe you are writing a program for your
school's library
and to be able to borrow books from the
library
a person either has to be a student of
your school or a member of the library
so we can have two booleans here
is
a student
which is false maybe this person is not
a student of your school
and
is the library
member is equals true maybe he is a
member of your library
[Music]
now to check whether this person is a
student or is a library member you can
use the logical or operator like this
system dot out
Dot println
and first we will check if this is a
student or not
student
or unlike the logical and operator you
have to use two pipe characters to
express the logical or operator and then
we will check
is Library member
I hope you remember that in order for
the operation to be true in case of a
logical and operation both sides of the
operator had to be true but in case of
the or operation if either side of the
operator is true the entire operation
will be true
so as you can see although easy student
is false given is Library member is true
the operation gives us the result true
so if if you turn both of these booleans
to true
the result will still be true
and the only case when you will get a
false result
is if both of these booleans are false
yes false
and finally there is another type of
logical operator in Java which is the
not operator
the not operator in programming usually
reverses
a Boolean value for example here
the value of the easy student Boolean is
clearly false right if if you run the
program it will surely print out false
but
if we put a not operator in front of
this this this exclamation sign is
actually the not operator and run the
program
you will see that it it turns out as
true so instead of using the not
operator over a single Boolean value you
can actually reverse the value of an
entire and or or a person in Java like
this let's go back a few steps
and I I hope you remember that in this
case we got the result false because
both of these booleans are false
now if you put a not operator in front
of the Esky student Boolean this will be
turned to true
so now if I run the program the result
of the entire operation will be true
yes there you go the different types of
operators that you have learned about so
far easily work with multiple operands
at a time
except the not operator it usually works
on a single value or variable at a time
now these kind of operators that usually
work with a single operand is usually
called
unary operators apart from the not
operator there are also two more
operators
that are unary in nature and very
commonly used in programming these are
the increment operator and decrement
operators
assume that you are trying to make a
game where you have to store the score
of the player and the number of turns
left now you can store these values in
two different integer numbers maybe
named score and turns
now whenever you have to increase the
value of score by 1 you can do so by
saying score plus equals one you have
already learned about the usage of the
arithmetic operators along with the
assignment operator in previous lessons
well this is one way to do this using
this method you can actually add any
number pre-score
but since here in this code you will
only increase the score by one
well you may think that what kind of
gain that is that gives you one in every
term well that's just for the example
okay just very good
you can do it like plus plus
so putting two double plus signs after
an integer or maybe float or double or
any number kind out there will increase
its value by one similarly you can put
2 minus signs to decrease or decrement
the value of a number time now if we
print out the values of these two
variable with
system dot out Dot println
score
and we will just
make a copy of this line
and change it to terms
you will see
that the value of score
is now 1
and the value of turns is now 9. so this
is pretty simple incrementing and
decrementing values there is nothing
fancy until I I make it a bit complex
let me show you something let's get rid
of all this code and declare a new
integer it's called number
and maybe its value is 55.
now if I say system dot out dot print Ln
a number
plus plus
you may think that this will print out
56 because
you know the
EU increment 55 by 1 and it becomes 56
well let's see if if that's true or not
hmm
seems like that the value has not
incremented at all okay let's make a
copy of this line
foreign
and run the program again
this time the value has changed but
at line 5 where you have used the plus
plus or the increment operator the value
remained unchanged but on line 6 while
you have haven't used any uh operator at
all the value seems to be incremented or
you see when the compiler reads your
code it usually goes from left to right
so when it comes to
system.out.println and sees the number
variable here it immediately prints out
its value
so at that point the value of number
will be 55.
then it sees that there is
an increment operator here and it goes
like Oh that means I have to increase
the value by 1 as well
then the compiler increases the value of
number 256 and keeps that in memory so
if you ever print out the value of
number later on it will actually print
out 56.
now this is same for the minus minus
sign or the decrement operator
initially the value will be 55 even
though the value has changed in the
memory and on the second pretty
statement it prints out 54.
so far I have showed you only one way of
writing the increment or decrement
operator instead of writing it at the
end you can also put it in front like
this
and let's see what output we get in this
case
as you can see this time we are getting
56 because when the compiler reads your
code from left to right it goes like
system.out.printellin and it immediately
encounters the increment operator and
then it sees the number and goes like
okay so I have to increase the value of
number and then print it out so it
prints out 56 on line 5 and on line 6 as
well
same goes for the decrement operator
54 and 54. so this is something that you
should be aware of when using the
increment or decrement operator inside
other statements like in this case the
println method call
if you are just incrementing or
decrementing the number outside of
anything like this method called like
this number plus plus
then you shouldn't have any problem at
all
see so if you ever get like unexpected
values after using the incremental
decrement operator in your program just
make sure that you are using it
correctly or you are using it in the
right place I hope that you remember in
a previous lesson I have taught you
about the character type it is one of
the Primitive types in Java and you can
store any Unicode character in it like
in this example I have stored the
percentage sign in a character variable
called the percent sign and I have
printed out the character on my console
using the standard
system.out.printlend method
now the character type is good and
everything but if you want to store
multiple characters together for example
your name or a sentence you cannot use a
character for that
for this type of scenarios we have
string in Java there are multiple ways
of declaring a new string
let's see the literal way first
so instead of
car
you will need to type a string
with a capital s
and then name of the string in this case
name
and then the value
so this is my name you can put any
string right here and then you can print
it out like
any other variable in Java
let's run the code
foreign
to declare a string in Java is by using
the new keywords the new keyword in Java
can be used to create new objects from
classes now we have not discussed
classes at all in this course yet but we
will get into classes and objects and
object rendered programming later on for
now just remember that the new keyword
can be used to create a new object from
a class
Now to create a string using the new
keyword you will have to write string
then the name of the string
equals new
string and the value
like if you run the program there should
be no change whatsoever because
essentially declaring the string this
way or that way it doesn't make any uh
visible changes to the program but there
is a slight difference in in these two
techniques now the jvm or the Java
virtual machine usually uses a portion
of your computer's memory to store
strings now this little portion of
memory is usually called the string pull
now whenever you create a new string in
the literal way
Java will first check whether this
string Farhan has injury already exists
in the string pull or not
if it does then the jvm will simply
reuse that previously string with a new
name
but in case of the new keyword the gvm
will create a new object regardless of
whether this value already exists in the
pool or not
I think this can be demonstrated with an
example very well
for this I will create four strings
first one string
literal E string 1 equals to A B C
and I'll create another literally string
with the same value but different name
there you go
now I will create two object string
I mean don't get me wrong these strings
are actually same but I am just naming
them as literally string and object D
string to make clear that
which is what
now object
string
equals to new string
maybe e f g
or XYZ
[Music]
so I'll make a copy of this string
change its name to object string 2 with
the same value
now if I compare these four strings with
each other like this
print Ln
literal
string one
equals equals literal string two
and I'll make a copy of this line
and use object string instead of literal
ones
sorry
let's make this wider so that the code
becomes easier to read and now if you if
we run the code
as you can see when declaring a new
string using the literal format
since the value ABC was already present
in the string pool that jvm actually
reused the older value with literally
shrink to but when using the new keyword
even though the same value has been
assigned to the two string variables
they are not same you have already
learned that the W equals sign checks
for the two objects are same or not and
in this case the literally strings are
actually same since they are using the
same value from the pool
and the objective strings are different
entities because they are not reusing
the same values from the pool
now depending on your Necessities you
may go with either of these techniques
but I'd suggest that you go with the
literally string
technique if there is no problem with
that because this will not only make
your code easier to read there is no new
or there is no duplicate is string
written in the code but also it will let
the compiler optimize your code a little
bit
but the strings in Java are not
primitive types these are object types
and the strings are literally one of the
most powerful types in Java you will use
strings a lot throughout your entire
programming carrier and there are a lot
of methods that we can use with this
Stream So now I will demonstrate a few
of those essential method that you can
use on strings and do fancy things with
this depending on the type of software
you are working on you may or may not
have to work a lot with string
formatting
now let me explain this topic with an
example
first I would suggest that
you go back to the Stacked layout from
side by side because now our code will
get a lot longer sideways and not
vertically
okay let's begin by removing everything
and writing a single system Dot
out dot print as an statement and in
here we will write a pretty long
sentence this time
Chase hello
world I am sorry
I am
from Bangladesh and
I am 26 years old
very simple program
if we run it
here so you're getting the entire line
without any changes
now we can take out a bunch of stuff
from this line such as my name
then uh my country name
[Music]
finally my age
now to use these variables inside this
string you can use the plus sign you you
may have already seen example of using
the plus sign to like slotting Dynamic
variables inside the strings
you can do the same here so I'll get rid
of farhanasan Chaudhary and in the
string here
[Music]
so now
the first string starts here and ends
here
the second one is starts here and ends
right here
and in between the two strings I put my
name
next I can take out the country name as
well
so I will separate the strings put two
plus signs and put country in here
nice finally the AIDS
same drill
separate the string to
plus signs and the variable name
okay let's save the code cross our
fingers and run it
yeah as you can see the output is fine
but I hope you are getting a sense of
how complicated this string can get once
you start adding more variable sites
such as if I add my company name the
company word for
uh company girls let's say free code
camp
a really nice place to work at
so I can change it to I work or
and then
plus plus
company
now you can put plus and a DOT
yeah works just fine so the point I'm
trying to get through is the fact that
Azure string grows and you start to use
more and more variables in it using the
plus sign to concatenate strings or add
them together becomes really clumsy
there is a better way to do this
and that's formatting your restraints
so let's declare another string called
formatted string equals then we will
write
is string Dot
format
so my name
is modulus
s
I am from
modulus is
[Music]
I am
modulus T years old
[Music]
and I work or modulus s so once we have
written this line we will say comma
so my name is modulus s so this modulus
is
or modulus D these characters are called
format specifier so when the Java
compiler comes and reads your line like
this my name is modulus is the compiler
knows that there will be a certain
string here and when it reads I am
modulus D years old the compiler will
know that there will be an integer
number here but the compiler doesn't
know yet what is string or what integer
value will replace this format
specifiers
so once you have finished writing your
string along with the format is
specifiers you will have to put a comma
and then put in the variables in the
same order of the formatting specifiers
for example we have my name is modulus s
and we want to replace this part with a
name variable so we will put name
then we will put a comma
and then I am from modulus s and we want
to replace this format specifier with
the country name so country
comma then we have modulus D which we
want to replace with the h
finally we have one more modulus s that
we want to replace with the company name
that's full stop here
there you go now we have a formatted
string so instead of writing this a long
string with plus signs and variable
names and what not in it we can just
write
for method
string
let's run the code
and as you can see it works out just
fine
so far you have seen the format
specifiers or strings and integers there
are also certain formative specifiers
for floating Point numbers and booleans
so the format is specifier for a
floating Point number B it a float or a
double in Java is modulus f
so if I put in a double here like
Maybe by GPA
equals
uh
three point
eight
and this is not real
and I can write
my GPA is modulus F and we can replace
this modulus if
with the value of GPA
foreign
excellent
finally
the format is specifier for a character
is modulus C and A Boolean is modulus B
now I can't think of any fun example to
demonstrate modulus B and modulus C
but I'll just go with it okay
maybe character
percent sign equals to put the percent
sign here
and I can say I have attended
100
percent
of my University classes
excellent and after the GPA I can just
use a comma and put percent sign here
cool
then
let's put a Boolean as well
Boolean
m i telling the
truth
equals false now I'm not reading the
truth I I haven't added 100 of my
classes and my GPA is also not 3.8
so
[Music]
um
am I telling the truth yeah right these
are all modulus B planes
and I can put a comma here
and then am I telling the truths yeah
that's a really horrible name to be
honest
let's run the program again
excellent my name is Farhan Hassan
Chaudhary I'm from Bangladesh I am 26
years old I work for free code Camp my
GPS 3.8 I have attended 100 of my
University classes these are all false
claims
so as you can see the string dot format
method returns a formatted string by
replacing all the specified format
specifiers with your given values now
instead of saving this formatted string
in a separate variable like I have done
here you can actually just copy the
entire thing
and paste it inside the println call
although it works and you can do this if
you want but I would not suggest doing
this because
there is something called the printf
function that you will learn later on in
this course that actually lets you uh
use the formative specifiers right in
the print function
so for now I would suggest that you save
your formatted string in a different
variable and then print that out using
println or use that however you see fit
so remember the format is specifier for
a string is
modulus
s
for an integer number also for shorts
and Longs is for modulus d
for floating Point numbers both floats
and doubles
modulus f
or characters
modulus C
and finally for booleans
modulus B
while working with strings in Java it's
really common to check the length of a
string or you may want to check whether
a string is empty or not like a lot of
things in Java doing these two tasks is
really easy
let's start with a single string okay
so extreme
name
Farhan has seen
I have to check the length of this
string you can write
first the name of the string which is
name then Dot
length
the length is a method that remains
inside every string that you create in
Java now if you run the code
as you can see the length of the string
is 22 which means there are 22
characters in the entire name including
the spaces in between okay
now you can also check whether a string
is empty or not
to do so you can just write the name of
the string which is name in this case
and then Dot and is
empty this is another method that
returns either true or false if the
string is not empty then it will return
false and if it's empty then it will
return true let's run the code and the
output in this case should be false
since the string actually contains some
characters in it now if I get rid of the
name inside the string and just
put two quotation marks with nothing in
between them and run the code again this
time the string will be treated as an
empty string and the output will be true
now the length and is empty methods can
be pretty useful in certain scenarios so
I would suggest that you remember them
and practice their usage as you go along
you can also convert strings from
lowercase to uppercase or uppercase to
lowercase in Java to do so first you
will need a string
then to convert this string to uppercase
you just need to write the name of this
string which in this case is same then a
DOT and two upper
case
this is a method and
if you run this program
you will see that the name has become
uppercase however you may think that
these two uppercase method has actually
changed the original string which is not
true
so if we add another println here
printing out the original name you will
see
foreign
variable is actually unchanged
you can also convert the name to lower
guess by using the
two lowercase method
and this will convert the entire string
to lowercase
there you go in a previous lesson I have
taught you two ways to declare new
strings in Java there was the literal
way that usually reuses the string value
if it's found in the string pool and
then there was the usage of the new
keyword and I hope that you also
remember that when you created a string
using the new keyword like this
difficult to new string and the value
can be something like a b c
then make a copy of it
and put a string two
with the same value
and try to compare them using the equals
equals operator or the equality operator
like this
stem dot out dot print Ln is string 1 is
equals equals string
you will see
that the output of this operation
comes out as false
this is because even though the value of
the two string is same these are not the
same object and the equality operator
usually checks whether
the object on the left side is same as
the object on the right side or the
object on the right side is same as the
object on the left side now to compare
strings you will have to instead use the
equals method so we'll first write the
name of one of the strings
then equals
and string two
let's run the program once again
and this time the output is true
however if you change the second value
of ABC to Capital ABC
sure the output will be false this time
since the values are not same
but there can be cases where you want to
check whether a string is equal to
another string or not ignoring their
cases
so for those scenarios you can use the
equals
ignore
case method instead of the regular
equals method
so as you can see even though the two
strings have different casing the output
is still true you can also replace a
part of a string in Java to do so first
you will need a string
such as
the sky is blue
[Music]
and then say for example we would like
to replace the word blue with the red
hair
system dot out
Dot println
uh string which is the name of our
string right now and then replace
you'd like to replace the word blue
three great
then run the program and see what the
output is
as you can see the word blue has indeed
been replaced with red now you may think
that the replace method changes the
original string but it doesn't
there you go what it actually does is it
replaces the white blue with red in the
string and Returns the updated string as
a new one
so instead of putting it directly into
the println method you can also do
something like a string
updated string equals to
this
and then put updated string inside the
println method
so this will give us the same result as
before
foreign
you may not always want to replace a
substring within a string but you may
want to check whether a string contains
a certain word or substring or not
you can do so in Java as follows
so we will use our previous string which
says the sky is blue and we'll check
whether this string contains the word
sky or not to do so you will say string
which is the name of our string here
then a DOT and then contains
and you will need to pass the string
that you want to check for to the
contains method in this case it's sky
save the code and run it
since the string contains the word Sky
the output is true but if you put
something that is not present within the
string such as free quote cam
and run the code
the output is false
back when I was learning to code for the
first time one of the things that I
learned and it gave me a sense of
achievement was being able to take input
from the user so far in this course you
have learned about different types of
data operators and outputting text on
the console in this lesson I will show
you how you can take different types of
inputs from the user as well as print
out text on the console in some other
formats if you are familiar with
programming languages like python where
taking input is a matter of a single
line you may be disappointed to learn
that in Java you have to write quite a
bit of code to take an input from the
user now the first thing that you need
to take input from the user is something
called an scanner object now scanner is
one of the classes in Java and you can
use the new keyword to create a new
scanner object from the class
so you begin by writing scanner
since the type of the object will be
scanner and you can name it anything but
I prefer naming it something simple like
scanner
then equals new
scanner
and you will have to let it know from
where you are getting the input so since
you will get the input from the console
or The Terminal you will have to write
system dot in
now this scanner class that you are
seeing here it doesn't exist in your
program yet
you will have to import it first so
before the first line where you declare
the class you will have to write import
Java dot util dot scanner
now you may be seeing this import
statement for the first time here but
it's nothing complicated there will be
scenarios where a certain class will not
be a part of your current program or
your current class and you will have to
import it from somewhere else
so the Java language comes with a lot of
such classes that can be really useful
in different scenarios this scanner
class is one of them
so once you have defined the new scanner
object you can take input from the user
so first I would like to speed out
something informative on the screen like
system dot out Dot print Ln
what is your name
and then I'll in the line here and I
will say
scanner
Dot next line
that's it
now the scanner dot next line method can
be used to take strings as input from
the user
you will have to save this input
somewhere though so you can say
a string name equals scanner dot next
line
then you can print it out
just let's print out the name for now
okay let's run the program and and see
if it works or not
okay as you can see there is this
quickly line under scanner and if you
hover over it it says resource link
scanner is never closed well what it
essentially says is once you are done
with the scanner you will have to close
it it's like an Open Door so if you if
you do not close it it will be active on
the memory so you will have to go like
scanner Dot close and this quickly line
should go away
yes it did
yeah now the programming's fine let's
run it
yeah what is your name okay
enter and yeah it prints out my name
pretty nicely now
you may notice
that
inputting my name after the prompt like
what is your name then inputting my name
in the next line may look a bit little
bit weird so instead of using the
println method what we can use here is
the print method so the print method is
actually similar to the println method
but the main difference is that it
doesn't have a new line character at the
end of the line
let me show you
so as you can see now the text prompt is
right after the question marks
so I can say for huh
yeah enter and yeah that's nice
now in case of a println method there is
usually a new line character at the end
so this causes the text cursor to go to
the next line
let's run the code to see how it changes
our output
yeah as you can see now it mimics the
behavior of the print element
okay
now apart from the print method there is
another useful cousin of this print
alone method called the printf
in a previous lesson I have showed you
how you can create formatted strings
using different types of format
specifiers and I also told you that
there is a variation of the print Ln
method that lets you use this format
specifiers right within the print method
okay that's that's the printf method or
print formatted now instead of just
printing out the name like this we can
say
hello
modulus s
[Music]
how are you
and then we will put a comma
and we would like to replace the modulus
with the name so we put name I hope you
remember all the different affirmative
specifiers that you have already learned
about if not you can just go back and
re-watch that lesson let's run the
program again
foreign
treats me and also asks how am I okay
let's
do something more
so you have learned that the next line
method usually gives back a string from
the user but you can also ask for
specific data types such as maybe an
integer
so to do so let's modify the next print
Affair so hello Farhan
how old are you okay
and then we would say int age equals to
scanner Dot
next Clint okay
yeah nice
and we would like to print out
yeah and sorry not printed on print f
modulus D is an excellent age to start
programming okay
like any age is like accidental learn
programming so
you know
and we will put age here so this modulus
D part will eventually be replaced by
the age
variables
okay let's run it
what is your name okay my name is Farhan
how old are you 26 maybe yeah
26 is an excellent age to start
programming nice I like it
okay now so far so good like the next
line method and next int method there
are also methods for double like scanner
dot next Double and next float and all
those different types that you can think
of
but one thing that I would like to draw
your attention to and something that
catches a lot of uh Java beginners or
card is a little quirk so as you can see
I am asking for the name using the next
line method then I'm asking for the age
using the next int method and it works
out just fine but let me show you what
happens if I try to use another next
line method after this next int method
okay
so if I say system dot out dot print Ln
or PDF
okay let's just reuse this line okay
some excellent cage just start
programming
what language
do we pray for
yeah
and after that we'll say
string language equals to scanner dot
next line
okay
Extreme Dot out Dot printf
modulus is is a very
popular programming
language
will stop
close here now
sorry I I missed the language here
yeah
now look carefully what happens when I
run the program okay so I run the
program
so first it asks for my name Chase
Farhan
sure ask how old am I so 26
and then it skips the last prompt where
I'm asking about the programming
language preference and just insta
program abruptly and the worst part is
there is no error or no failure at all
which can help you to debug this problem
well this is something uh this has to do
with the way the next end and the next
line method works so let me explain
so when you are saying a string name
equals to scanner dot next line and I'm
inputting my name then I'm pressing
enter
the next line method is actually taking
the entire name along with my enter or
my new line character at the end or the
character when I press enter that goes
as an input
but when it comes to the next int method
it only takes the number or 26 as an
input and leaves the new line character
or carriage return in the buffer in the
input buffer so what happens is when I
say at 26 and then I press enter
this part will be consumed by this
method next end but the enter will be
left in the input buffer
so
so when the second next line call comes
it sees that there is already an enter
in the input buffer and mistakes it as a
Enter key press from me
so it assumes that the user has already
inputted the text they wanted to input
and
insta call right there okay I hope it
makes sense
now there are multiple ways to like deal
with this problem and
one of the ways is whenever you put a
next in call or next Double call or next
float call whatever it is except next
line then you will have to put
okay
an extra scanner dot next line here so
this just like cleans up the input
buffer
so this next line method eats up the
enter that was left
by the next int and cleans the input
buffer so if we run the program now
okay let's say forehan
and how about am i 26
what language do you prefer well Java
yeah
so this is something that you should
keep in mind that whenever you are using
a next ink call anything but a next line
call and you want to put another next
line call after that like we have here
an extent and the next line you will
have to put an extra scanner dot next
line call just to clean up the input
buffer just to get get rid of that uh
leftover Enterprise okay otherwise your
program May skip the next call okay
another way to
deal with this situation is instead of
using methods like next end or next
float you can just use next line for
taking all the inputs and then once you
have taken an input you can just
like convert it to something else okay
for example uh instead of using the next
ink if we use the next line method here
and
this will give us a string
so what we can do is we can say integer
dot parse int
and then put the scanner dot next line
in there
okay
and let's run the program and see what
happens
on 86
um Java yeah it works out just fine and
we do not have to use any extra scanner
objects as well now if you had like
instead of int you may have like uh
double here you can do so a double say
for example if we uh want to take the
GPA of the user equals to to be the
double
Dot
first double
and then scanner Dot next one
and this will work out too okay so uh
all of the first method that we have in
these classes like integer.parsing
double dot purse double we can use all
of this now you may think that how would
I know uh which method to use when you
are trying to purse a number from a
string well uh one way that I suggest
everyone is you can just Google it uh
saying how to purse integer from a
string in Java or maybe how to purse a
double from a string in Java and so on
or this is something that I would leave
up to you to figure out because this is
something that you do not learn in
courses
okay so I hope you have learned about
taking inputs from the user the main
thing you need is a scanner object and
you will have to let it know from where
you are getting your input
uh you can also take input from a file
and some other places but those are a
bit of advanced
for what you know at the moment and you
will also have to remember to import the
scanner class first otherwise the code
will just fail okay if I comment this
out and run the code you will see the
program simply fails to find the scanner
class
it says cannot find symbol so make sure
that you have imported the class at the
top here
and the rest is pretty simple I guess so
now that you have learned about taking
input from the user and outputting text
on Console using printf print and
println
uh in the next lessons we will learn
about something called the conditional
statements and we'll make a very simple
calculator project that will just show
you how much you can do
with what you have already learned
now you have already learned about The
Logical operators and taking input from
user to all the most important things in
programming in this lesson I will teach
you something called conditionally
statements that lets you make logical
decision based on some conditions and
Branch out your code in different ways
for example we will make a calculator in
this lesson and we will let the user
perform addition subtraction
multiplication and division operations
uh based on their inputs
so first we will need a scanner of
course
and let's
get rid of all this code
okay yeah so you need to close the
scanner as well okay let's begin with a
double
double
number one
equals to scanner dot next Double
and then we will also do
number two
scanner dot next w
we need to output something on this
screen as well
print is on
sorry let's use print here
enter the first number
and then
we'll put enter the second number
it's
and let's just output the numbers to
make sure that the input is working fine
number one
and then let's make a copy of this line
number two
yes let's run the code
five
and ten
yeah looks like the input is working
fine
now we'll need to ask the user what
operations they want to perform for that
let's
speed out
what operation
do you want to
perform
and okay we will use print instead of
print alone and then we will have to
take a string input
it's a string
operation equals to scanner dot next
line
so as I have already told you that this
next Double calls will leave two next
line characters in the input buffer so
we will need to clear them out first so
let's just put this extra calls here
and once we have taken the string
operation
then we can check what it is okay
so the if statements in Java or in
programming in general lets you check uh
whether a certain value meets a certain
condition or not for our case we can say
if
then a set of parentheses operation
Dot
equals
sum
so if the user has written some as the
name of the operation then
what you want to do is system dot out
Dot println and we will say not println
printf
modulus D plus modulus T equals to
modulus D comma so we want to replace
the first modulus D with number
one
this should have been F actually since
you're working with double sir and not
integers
then
number two finally number one plus
number two
space them out in the line with the
semicolon
excellent now
let's check out our simple calculator
and see if we can do the summation
correctly or not
so the first input will be five you can
put anything you want the second number
will be 10.
what operation do you want to perform
okay sum
yeah 5 plus 10 equals 15. now what
happens if I put anything but sum okay
for now we are checking if
the operation is equals to sum or not
and this will return true
if it returns true then the line inside
the if statement will be executed but
what happens if we input something else
let's check it out
ten two
maybe subtraction or sub you see nothing
happens so for situations where an if
statement fails to fulfill the condition
we can put an else statement
and we can print out system dot out Dot
println
print F
modulus s is not a supported operation
and you can put a semicolon here and we
can say comma operation let's see how it
turns out
okay five
ten
what's up
sub is not a supported operation
excellent
now I have already said that we will
Implement a summation subtraction
multiplication and division
for that what we can do is we can put
lcv statement here so
if this condition fails
we can say
else
if
and we can put another condition here so
operation
dot equals
sub
then what do you want
copy this line
put it here
change the plus sign with minus and also
change the operation here
minus then we'd want to close this Gap
make it look good
so now what will happen the program will
ask for the first number then the second
number then ask for what kind of
operation the user wants to perform and
then first it will check if the
operation is equal to sum or not
if it's equal to sum then it will print
out the sum of the two numbers
if it's not the sum then the ladder will
check
whether the operation is equals to sub
or not if it's sub then it will perform
the subtraction operation and give out
the value and if the operation is not
sun and also not sub then it will go
into the else block and print out that
this is not a supported operation let's
check it out
foreign
Ty is larger than the first one
the value is negative similarly we can
just implement the multiplication and
division operations so let's just do
them else if
operation Dot equals
multiplication then
and just copy this entire line
and
yep
[Music]
yeah that's it
finally the division operation
is a little different operation equals
to div
then first we will have to check
we put another if inside this lcf and
this is called a nested if block so we
will check if
number two
is
equals equals zero
then we want to print out
system dot out dot print Ln
okay
cannot divide by zero because you just
cannot divide a number by zero and then
you will put else and
we'll perform the division inside
and we'll bring up the else block here
and now let's let's check out the
Division and multiplication operations
as well
let's put 10
0
and div
cannot divide by 0 excellent
let's rerun the program
enter the first number then
do
gives
five excellent finally the
multiplication operations
then
a mul a multiplication via 80. excellent
so we have already managed to create a
very simple calculator here capable of
Performing the basic arithmetic
operations using IF else
now I'm not saying that this is the only
way to implement a calculator you can
actually uh find even much better ways
of making calculators but so far what
you have learned this is a pretty good
implementation of all your knowledge
now when it comes to branching out your
code based on one or more conditions if
else's statements are pretty common but
this is not the only way of doing things
there is another statement called switch
case statement that can do the same
thing as a complicated if else ladder in
this lesson we will convert our
calculator application to use a switch
case statement instead of ifills
statements now before we dive into our
code I would like to go to settings and
change our layout
from stack to side by side because
as I'm seeing our code is becoming much
longer vertically and it's becoming
harder to read we can also make the
console smaller for now because we need
to focus on our code
now we can retain most of our code from
our previous example we can keep the
scanner the inputs for number one and
number two the input for the operation
and the only thing that we need to get
rid of is the Ifill statements
now instead of removing the code
entirely what I would do is
I will just comment it out
now
to write switch case statement in Java
you will have to begin by writing
switch
and then within a set of parentheses you
will have to put the variable that you
are trying to test
so if you remember from our efels
statement we are testing out the value
of the operation variable and see
whether it matches one of the four
operations or not so inside the switch
put operation
then we will put a set of curly braces
now you may have already guessed from
the name of switch case statements that
there will be multiple cases inside a
switch
now these cases are like this individual
if statements where you are checking the
value of the operation variable against
something
so in the first case of this statement
we will check whether the value of the
operation is some or not to do so you
will have to write case
and then the value you want to check
against which is sum in this case
then you will put a colon here
and on the next line you can put the
logic
for the summation
so I will just copy the code from our
previous evil slider and put it here
okay
let's run the code and see what happens
okay Enter the first number I
and put five into the second number 10
and stop
okay it says 15 which means it works now
try to put a value that is not defined
within the switches statement like sub
let's rerun the program
5 10
sub
and as you can see just like the if
statement when you didn't have an ill
server
it doesn't print out anything at all
now in case of switch cases statements
you do not have else but you will have a
default guess which you can write as
default
[Music]
and then you can just print out that
this is not a supportive operation
let's run the program and see what
happens
first number five
then
and
okay savvy's not a supported operation
fine now so far this looks okay but let
me show you a problem here
if I run the program
if I put the numbers
and then say sum
you will see the program not only prints
out the summation of the two numbers but
it also prints out is not a supported
operation
well the way switch cases are designed
that if one of the cases match then the
program will not only execute that case
but also the cases that comes after that
to stop the program from going through
all the cases here what you'll need to
do is you will
need to use the break step
so when the program comes and it sees
that the sum case has been matched it
will execute the logic here and then it
will encounter the break statement and
breakout of this entire switch case
statement okay and it will go directly
to scanner.close Let's test it out once
again
sorry
let's put five
then
and some
so as you can see it prints out the sum
and breaks the program right there
okay that that's cool
now
you can actually Define the other cases
such as
case
sub
and we will of course take the
subtraction logic from our previous efl
slider
put it here put the break statement in
let's just copy this
best okay so the third case would be the
multiplication case and
we'll change the minus sign so if the
multiplication sign
and finally the division case
[Music]
now I hope that you remembered that we
also had a check to make sure that the
user is not trying to divide by zero
we will have to do that as well and for
that we do not have anything fancy we
will just need to rely on plain old if
else step map so we will write
if
number two is equals equals zero
then we would like to print out
cannot divide by zero
else we would like to perform the
division operations
keep in mind that you should write the
break statement outside of both the if
and else block otherwise if you put the
break inside the if or the else then it
will only work if
one of them are active but if you put it
out here no matter what happens in DC
fills block the break will always work
let's try it out and see if it works or
not save the code
and run it again
okay then
zero
and div
cannot divide by zero okay let's rerun
the program and check if the normal
division function works or not
then
two
give
yeah it works finally let's check the
multiplication
[Music]
10 5 multiplication
50 yeah it works just fine
now you can get rid of the commented out
if it's a statements
now although e-fills statements and
switch cases statements are more or less
do the same thing in the context of Java
or in the context of other programming
languages as well
a switch case statement is actually
faster than an if else letter in Java so
if you can put your logic within a
switch case statement instead of a
really elaborate if else statement try
to do that so far in this course you
have only stored single values in single
variables but there is a way to put
multiple values within a single variable
these are called arrays
now before I start working on arrays
let's do some cleanup
you can get rid of more or less
everything in our code you can also get
rid of the Java util.scanner
now to declare a new array for example
if I want to declare an array of
characters and I want to store all the
vowels in English alphabets you can do
so like this
first you will have to type out the type
of the array which in this case is car
or character
space then the name of the array which
will be files
and
two square braces
then you will put an equal sign and new
car then you will put another set of
square braces and inside of these Square
braces you will have to put the length
of the array now we know that there are
five vowels in the English alphabet so
you will put five
now we have an array of characters but
it's completely empty to insert a new
value to this array you will have to
write
files
and then an index of the array which in
this case 0
then equals then the value you want to
save in the array
a
now I have already told you that this
array is of 5 length which means it can
store five characters in it
now these characters here can be stored
like a e i o u and each of this
character will have a number associated
with them this number is called the
index
now the first index of an array in Java
is always zero so by putting vowels and
0 inside a set of square braces you are
essentially addressing the first place
in this array
then you put equals a and you fill it up
now the other spaces are still blank
now you can copy this line
and paste it to insert the other values
as well so 0
then 1
.
then index 2 will be I
index 3
will be o
and finally index 4
will be you
you
now you have completely filled this
array with the five vowels of English
alphabet
you can also print out these individual
files using the same square brace syntax
so if I copy files to
from here
and write system dot out Dot println and
put files and two inside Square braces
and print it out you will see I printed
out on the console
yeah as you can see there is I
you can also print out an entire array
but
that's not as simple as printing out a
single character or number or a string
as you may have already guessed the
print printf or println function prints
out stuff on the console as strings
so before you can print out the array
you will have to convert it is string
to do so
import the arrays class like this import
java.util Dot erase
and then inside the println method call
you will write arrays
Dot
to string
and in the name of the array which in
this case
is vowels
see we have printed out the entire array
now you can also print out an array
using Loops which you will learn in
later lessons for now just be informed
that there is also other ways of
printing out an entire array to the
console
so I have already mentioned that this
array has a length of 5. and since its
index count starts from 0 it will
obviously end at 4. now if you try to
put something in an index that doesn't
exist
like five
and maybe put X here
run the program
you will see that it fails with an
exception saying index 5 out of bounds
for length 5 which means for an array of
length 5 you cannot have an index 5.
let's get rid of that line
and our code should be back to normal
now instead of declaring and defining
your arrays separately you can actually
declare and Define your array in one
line
to do so after you have written car
files
the pair of square braces and equal get
rid of the new keyword
and put a set of curly braces here
then you can actually put the values
[Music]
and in the line with the same colon
get rid of these lines here
and run the code
there you go
now you can also replace any of these
values from the array at any moment for
example if you want to replace the I
with any other character out there you
can do so
in this way
vowels
curly braces and the index of I is 0 1
2. so put 2 here
equals and put X
put a semicolon at the end run the
program
and as you can see the eye has indeed
been replaced with x
another thing that I forgot to mention
is the fact that when you are declaring
and defining your array in a single line
the array will actually infer its length
from the number of values you are
defining it with
so since there are five values in the
definition the areas length will always
be 5. the light strings arrays in Java
are reference types and like strings
arrays also have a bunch of useful
methods in them for example if you ever
want to know about the length of an
array you can do so by saying that let's
get rid of this line first
and you can write the name of the array
files and Dot left
I hope you remember that in case of a
string the length was actually a method
but in case of an array it's a property
so if we run the program
and you can see the length of the array
a one of the most common tasks regarding
arrays that you may have to do again and
again within your programs is sorting an
unsorted array
right now we have ordered our files
array according to the order of the
letter as they come in the English
alphabet so a e i o u
but if we change the order and kind of
randomize it so I will put e first
then u a
and I so a e i o u then it's totally out
of order
now there is a method called sort within
the arrays class that you can use to
sort your arrays in order
to do so you will have to write
arrays Dot sort
and then put the name of the array
balance
then let's bring back our
arrays.goo string method
and we'll save outs
let's run the program and see
if it works or not
so turns out that the arrays.sort method
takes an array as its parameter and it
sorts the array in place so it actually
changes the original Source array by
default the arrays.sort method performs
the Sorting on the entire array so it
will begin from the first letter and go
through the entire array until it
reaches the last letter and sort them in
order but if you want to perform the
Sorting within a certain range of the
array
let's say for example if I want to keep
the e and i as they are right now and I
just want to sort the u a and o I can do
so so after I have put the array name
now to define the starting and ending
index of the sort method
you can let's just Define to integer
cells so int
starting index equals I'd like to start
the Sorting from U so 0 1
[Music]
than in ending index
I want to perform the Sorting until all
but here is the thing
if I put
0 1 0 1 2 3 3 as the ending index
the O will be left out from the Sorting
because the ending index is usually not
inclusive in this case so I will have to
write 4. which means the Sorting will
take place from U to o n it will
actually not affect I
Let's test it out after I have written
the name of the array I will put a comma
here and I'll put the starting index
then the ending
index
save my code and run it
so as you can see
the sort method has actually sorted aou
in order and did not touch e and I at
all
so this is one of the useful things that
you should know about sorting arrays in
Java apart from sorting an array you may
also want to search for a certain value
within an array okay so for example we
have e u a o i here and if you want to
look for o in the entire array you can
do so by using the arrays.binary search
method
now one thing that you will have to
remember is that these areas.binary
search method only works on sorted
arrays so if you have an array that is
not in order make sure you have sorted
it before performing the search
now to search for maybe o within this
array I will say
arrays Dot
binary search
and then I'll put the name of the array
that I want to perform the search on so
files
and then the key or the item I am
looking for so I'll write key
and I create a new character here uh key
equals to and I'm looking for what I'm
looking for oh
okay now this binary search method right
here returns an integer which is the
index
of this key is found
so I will write int
found item index equals to errors dot
binary search files excellent
now first I would like to print out the
entire array
and then I would like to print out
the found item index
so found item
index
e
let's save the code and
test it out
sorry I mistyped the name of the
variable here you know mistakes like
this can happen
yeah
so in the array a e i o u o is at index
number three so we can verify that 0 1
2 and 3 o is at index number three like
the sort method that you learned about
just a few moments ago the arrays dot
binary search method can also take an
starting and an ending index
to use them first we will need to define
the index
integers like int starting index I think
I should have just kept them
and I will start
the search from one so I put one
then I will also create an ending index
equals to 4 because I want to perform
the search within the middle three
values and like the sort method
the ending index is not inclusive in
this case as well
so once I have defined the two integer
numbers I will say binary search vowels
and then
the starting index
comma the ending index
and finally the key I am looking for
now let's see if it works or not
run
okay so it says 3 which is correct in
this case as well I have found o at 0 1
2 3.
now so far in this lesson I have shown
you a bunch of searches and all of them
has worked out fine but what will happen
if one of your searches failed to find
the value you're looking for for example
we do not have an X in the entire array
so if I get rid of the starting and
ending index
and look for an X within our array
you will see that the output is -6 now
instead of looking for an X if I look
for a b within our
array you will see
that the output
changes from -6 to -2
so you may have already guessed that
depending on the item you are looking
for and if it doesn't exist within your
array then the output can differ
but one thing that's constant is if the
search fails you will always get a
negative output and if the search
succeeds you will get a positive output
and that positive number will be one of
the indexes from your array where the
item you are looking for exists now
there is a way to actually calculate
this value there is logic behind why the
output is sometimes 2 and sometimes six
but I will not get into that much
details in this course if you are
interested about learning this I will
leave the link to this article on free
code Camp under this video's description
so you can follow that link and read
more about it now being able to sort an
unsorted array and look for any certain
item within an array is useful now
another small but useful thing that you
can do with arrays is that you can fill
them with a certain value
for example we have five vowels listed
out of order within our vowels array
but maybe for some reason you want to
fill the entire array with x
or maybe empty characters
now you can do that by using the
arrays.fill method before that let's get
rid of some of these codes
and write arrays Dot
feel
then put the name of the array that you
want to fill which is files
and the character or the value that you
want to fill the entire array with
[Music]
let's run the code and see if it works
or not
yeah as you can see the entire area has
been filled with excess
now you can also have starting and
ending indices with this fill method
starting index equals let's start from
one
and in end ending
index equals to 4 this is the same drill
with the other methods as well the
ending index is never inclusive
so if you want to perform the field from
1 2 3 upon these three values make sure
to include the last one as well or the
item that's just after the one you want
to end the field action act okay now
arrays.fill comma vowels then we will
put the starting index
the ending index
finally the value that you want to fill
the array with
okay so rs.2 string valves let's see if
it works or not
yeah it does uh the E and I is untouched
and the U and O and A has been replaced
with x's I have already said that arrays
in Java are reference types and one of
the complexities that we get with any
reference types out there is making
copies of them
for example if we have an array of
integers this time just for changing our
test a bit I will write
int
numbers
same thing equals then inside of a pair
of curly braces I will put one two three
four and five
then I will create another array saying
int
copy of numbers which is an array
equals to
the number sorry okay
so ideally the copy of numbers array
should be a copy of the original numbers
right
let's see if that's true or not
print Ln
arrays dot two string numbers
let's make a copy of this line and put
copy of numbers
sorry
let's run the code and see what happens
turns out I have made another typo here
I have Mr T
let's put it back
and run the program
so it seems like that the copy of
numbers array is indeed a copy of the
original number setting
but I'm not convinced let's do another
thing okay
let's make some changes to the original
area so we can say
arrays Dot
fill
numbers and I'll fill the original array
with zeros
and then run the code let's see what
happens
but this is unexpected isn't it
I have actually made some changes to the
source arrays and the changes have
somehow applied to the copy as well
but the reason for this is the fact that
arrays in Java are reference types and
when you use an assignment operator to
make a copy of an array or any other
reference type
for that matter
it doesn't actually makes an entirely
new copy of the source material what it
does is it creates a new variable and
points that variable to the original
Source array
so although the second array has a
different name it's still pointing to
the same values so you can treat this
copy of numbers array as kind of an
alias for the original numbers area
so how do you make a copy of an array
correctly then now to copy an array
properly you will have to use
the arrays dot copy of method the method
takes the name of the original array as
its first argument and at the second
argument
it asks for the length of the new array
so the length of the original array as
we can see is one two three four five
so you can count that by hand or you can
be a little bit clever and put numbers
dot length as the length for the new
array
let's run the code and see whether the
copy gets affected by the field call or
not this time
so as you can see that the original
Source material and the copy of it are
now two separate entities which we want
now instead of putting the same length
as the original array you can also make
the array larger or smaller let's say
if you make it larger with 10
indexes you can do so
so as you can see the first five
elements of the copied array are from
the original array and the rest of the
indexes has been filled with 0 which is
the default value for integers you can
also make it smaller so 2
.
and the copy array can hold only two
values while the original array could
hold five
now like the sword
and the search method you can also
Define the starting and ending indexes
for the areas.copy of method but for
that instead of using the copy off
method you will have to use copy of
range now inside this method you will
have to first give it the name of the
source array
then and starting index and and ending
index
and just like before we will have to
Define this integers here and the
starting index
equals to Let's uh 0 1 let's start the
copy from one
and in
ending index equals to
r 4.
let's run the code and see what happens
so as you can see
the method has successfully copied 2 3
and 4 from The Source area now one thing
that you may have already noticed that
in case of the copy of range method you
do not need to use a link for the newly
copied array
so how can you increase the length of
the new array if you want to
well right now we are performing the
copy from
index number one to index number four
right
so if we put a larger value than the
original length of the array like
then let's see what happens
so as you can see the copy works out
fine the method copies 2 3 and 4 from
the original array also 5 and 10 fills
up the rest of the space with zeros
so although you cannot explicitly Define
a new length for your copied array you
can change the length of the new array
by
changing the ending index of the copy of
range method
just like copying a reference type is
more complex than copying A Primitive
type comparing preference style is also
a bit complicated I hope you remember
from our lessons on string we couldn't
compare two strings simply using the
equal SQL signs we had to actually use
the equals method
so it's kind of similar in case of
arrays say for example we have the
original numbers array
then we have a copy of the numbers array
let's just use
copy off instead
numbers dot length x length
and get rid of the field method
and try to compare our arrays using the
equality operator so we'll send numbers
equal equals
copy of numbers
let's run the code and see what happens
as you can see it says false but we know
for sure that the copy of numbers array
is an identical copy of the original
Source material
now to compare to identical arrays like
this or maybe two different arrays
what you'll have to do is you will have
to write
arrays dot equals
then inside this method you'll have to
pass the two arrays copy of numbers
let's run the code and see what happens
yeah this time it comes out as true
since there is no such thing as casing
in case of an array
there is no equals ignore case method
for arrays like we had for strings in
programming you may want to repeat a
certain set of instructions again and
again for your projects you can do that
by using loops now there are four kinds
of Loops in Java and we will start our
discussion with a for Loop first I will
write out the code
for a very simple for Loop in Java that
can print out the number from 1 to 10.
for that I will write
for this is the starting of our for Loop
then inside I will take an integer int
number equals to 1. now after the
semicolon I will write
number
is less than or equals
10.
and then number plus plus
then I will put
a set of curly braces here and inside
this block of code I will write
system dot out
Dot println
number
we do not need the arrays class import
right now so we will get rid of that
and let's run the code and see what
happens then I will explain each line of
this for Loop to you
as you can see the program successfully
prints out
all the numbers from 1 to 10. so what's
going on here well every single for Loop
usually has
four parts the first part
is the initialization where we are
initializing a certain variable in this
case an integer with the initial value
of 1.
then there is a condition that we are
checking against so we are checking
whether the number is less than or equal
to 10 or not
and if the number is less than or equal
to 10 we will print out the number so
this is the loop body system.out dot
println anything that you write inside
this set of curly braces will be the
loop body
then once we are done with the loop body
we will go to the third part here inside
the set of parentheses and this is
called the update and we will update the
value of the number variable
so I will repeat
every single for Loop will have four
parts there is the initialization where
we initialize a variable with a value
then there is a condition that we will
check in every iteration there is the
loop body and then there is the object
so when this Loop runs for the first
time the value of number will be 1.
and this condition will be true since 1
is indeed less than 10. so the loop will
print out the value of number which in
this case is 1.
then the loop will increase the value of
number by 1 and go back to the condition
part and check whether the updated value
is less than or equal to 10 or not well
2 is less than 10
so it will again go inside the loop body
and print out 2 on the console
so like this the loop will keep printing
out all this number until it reaches 10.
when the loop has printed out 10 on the
screen it will go back to the update
part and increase the value of number
from 10 to 11. and it will go back to
the condition once again and check
whether 11 is less than or equal to 10
or not
in this case the condition will come out
as false and the loop will stop
iterating
the program ends here and we get all the
numbers between 1 to 10 printed out on
our console
I hope that makes sense you can also use
a for Loop to Loop over an array
for example if we create an array here
int
numbers
equals to
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and 10.
then we can use this for Loop to Loop
over this array and print out each of
this number
to do so we will need an integer and we
can call that the index
so we want to run this loop as long as
the index
is less than
the length of this array so
numbers
dot length
numbers dot length
finally we will increase the value of
index by 1 on every iteration
finally inside the println call we will
send numbers
and then we will put the index here
let's see if it works or not
so as you can see the program actually
brings out all the numbers from 2 to 10
and doesn't print out to 1 because
since the index count starts from 1
which
is its initial value it starts accessing
the array elements from index one so if
you change the value of index from 1 to
0 then you should get all the numbers
from 1 to 10.
so what's happening here is you are
initializing an integer with a value of
0
and then inside the condition part you
are checking whether the value of the
index is less than the length of the
numbers array or not if it's less than
the length of the numbers array then you
go inside the loop body and print out
whatever number is in the current index
so it starts from index 0 which means
one
then index 1 which is 2 then 3 4 5 6 and
so on
you can also do some interesting things
within this Loop instead of printing out
all the values
you can add them all together and print
out the sum to the screen
to do that what you will need is you
will need another integer here
goes to zero
initially the sum will be zero
and then inside the loop what we are
going to do is we will say sum plus
equals
numbers
and then the index
okay finally we'll move out this system
dot out Dot println outside of this Loop
and print the sum on the screen
let's see what happens when you run the
code I forgot the semicolon here yeah
so the sum of all the numbers from 1 to
10 is 55. now let me show you two more
interesting programs that you can write
using a for Loop
the first one is that you can print out
multiplication tables of any number
using nested for loops
for that what we need is a number so we
will Begin by taking a new integer in
number
pi
then inside the for Loop let's get rid
of all this code and rewrite the for
loop from scratch so we will say for
then another integer the multiplier we
will begin from one then if the
multiplier
is less than 10 we will keep going
and we'll also increase the value of
multiplier by 1.
then inside the loop body we can say
system dot out Dot
print F in this case
modulus D into modulus D is equals
modulus t
now we will say number
then the second part would be the
multiplier
and finally number into multiplier
now I hope you remember that the printf
method doesn't have any new line
character at the end
so if you run the program at its current
state let's see what happens
as you can see it prints out the entire
multiplication table in a single line
which we do not want
so what we can do is we can put a
backslash n at the end of the line which
will print out each row in a new line
run the program
excellent
now we can take it a bit further to the
audience
let's get rid of the current code
and let's begin with the new for Loop
okay
for inch number
equals one
number is less than 10.
and number
plus plus
then inside the for Loop we will have a
nested for loop I hope you remember that
we have worked with nested if statements
in the past we can also nest for Loops
within each other so we can do 4
into multiplier equals one
multiplier is less than 10 and
multiplier
plus plus
now inside the loop body we will say
system dot out Dot
printf
modulus T into modulus T equals to
modular state
so the first thing would be the number
so
since
the nested for Loop is inside the outer
for Loop any variable declared within
the outer for Loop will be accessible
inside the nested folder but any
variable that you declare inside the
nested Loop such as this multiplier here
will not be visible to the Outer Loop so
we can send number so we will replace
the first modulus D with a number
then we will say
multiplier
and finally number into multiplier
in the line
save our code
and let's run it
okay just like before we have to add a
new line character at the end
to make it look a bit nicer
so as you can see now we have
successfully printed out the
multiplication table for all the numbers
from one
to nine
but if you would like to include 10 here
you can say less than or equal
and then run the code
yeah it works fine and I also just
noticed that we are missing again here
and
you can fix that by saying multiplier is
less than or equal to 10. right
so let me explain what happens here
first inside the outer for Loop you are
initializing a number with one and you
are continuing to Loop until the value
of number exceeds 10 so less than or
equal 10
and then inside the loop body you have
another loop
so first it comes and says okay number
is equals one it's less than 10 then it
goes inside the inner for Loop and it
sees that there is a multiplier with the
value of one multipliers value is less
than 10 then it goes inside the body
once a body has been executed
it prints out one into one equals one
and then it goes back to the update part
of the inner loop and it checks again
then it keeps looping within the inner
loop once the value of multiplier has
exceeded 10
the inner loop breaks and the program
goes back to the outer loop it increases
the value of number by 1 which becomes 2
now and it goes inside the inner loop
again and prints out the multiplication
table for two then it goes on to print
out three
four five six seven eight nine and ten
so if you're having difficulty
deciphering this complicated code here I
would suggest that you write this code
yourself and use a notebook to
understand
how these values changes in each
iteration okay so finally I would like
to show you an example of using an if
else statement within afford for example
if I tell you to print out all the odd
numbers from 1 to 50 you can do that by
using a for Loop and a single if else
statement let's begin
for
int number equals one
number is less than or equals to 50.
number plus plus so this Loop will begin
at one and end at 50.
then inside the loop body what we want
to do is we want to check
if
number
modulus 2
is equals equals one
then system dot r dot println
number
[Music]
so if you divide a number by 2 and the
remainder is 1 it's pretty sure that
the number is an odd number we all know
that
so what we are doing is inside the for
Loop we are taking whatever the value of
number is we are dividing that by 2 and
checking if the remainder is one or not
that's what the modular operator is for
I hope you remember and if the number is
an odd number we will print it out and
if it is an even number we will skip
that let's run the code and see what
happens
so as you can see we have successfully
printed out all the on odd numbers from
1 to 50 so 1 3 5 7 9 11 13 15 and it
goes on to 45 47 and 49.
there is another variant of the for Loop
that makes looping over collections such
as array is much easier
now for that first we'll need an array
numbers
equals uh I'll just put the regular
numbers here
there you go
now
to use this special type of for Loop you
will have to write
for
then inside you will say int number this
type has to match with the type of the
array
and then you will put a colon here and
then you will put the name of the array
then inside the area body you can say
system dot out dot print Ln number
let's see what happens
so as you can see the loop successfully
goes through the entire array and prints
out each element to the console now
What's Happening Here is uh you are
saying for every single integer number
in the numbers array you want to print
them out so instead of using an integer
as an index and accessing the elements
individually you are kind of taking a
shortcut
and extracting each value from the
numbers array and putting them in the
number variable on each iteration now
you can do anything that you could have
done in a regular for Loop such as if
you want the sum of all these numbers
you can do so like this
some classicals number
[Music]
and then system dot out Dot println
it's so make sure you are putting the
printerland call outside of the loop
otherwise this will be printed every
single time the loop iterates let's run
the code and see what happens
there you go other than the for Loop
there is also the while loop and do
while loop in Java these are two
different kinds of Loops that can more
or less do the same thing as a for Loop
but the for Loops are a lot more common
in the wild than the while Loops now I
will show you two examples of using a
while and two while loop first let's
begin with the while loop
we will simply print out the
multiplication table like we did in the
case of the for Loop but this time we
will use a while now first you will need
a number
just like before
then you will need the multiplier
now to write a while loop you will have
to say while
multiplier is less than or equals 10
then inside the loop body you will say
system dot out Dot printf
modulus T into modulus T equals modulus
T since all of the variables are
integers in this case then you will put
number
then the multiplier finally the number
into multiplier
excellent then once you have printed out
the row in the multiplication table you
will have to
increase the multiplier by 1.
multiplier plus plus
let's run the code and see what happens
so here looks like the program works
just fine we have to just put a new line
character to make the output a bit more
readable
foreign
there you go
now the main difference between a while
loop and a for Loop is the fact that the
while loop only has one component which
is
the condition in case of a for Loop we
had the initialization we had the
condition we had the loop body and we
also had the update part but in this
case there is just the condition and of
course we have the loop body so you will
have to do the initializations
outside of the loop and you will have to
perform the update or
the incrementation of the multiplier or
maybe counter or whatever you are
working with
inside the loops body
so this is how a while loop looks like
now a do while loop
Works similarly but in a different order
and also looks a bit different so in
case of a do while loop you will have to
write do
then you will have the loop body
which in our case is these two lines we
want to print out the multiplication
table once again and also increase the
multiplier
and after the loop body you will say
while
multiplier is less than or equals 10.
let's comment out our old while loop
make our console bigger and run the code
foreign
output now the main difference between a
regular while loop and a two white Loop
is the fact that in this case first the
loop body will be executed and then the
condition will be checked whereas in
case of a while loop the condition gets
evaluated and then the loop body gets
executed so you will surely find usage
of both kind of Loops if you worked long
enough
but I can say from experience that for
Loops are a lot more common than whites
or do vials
let's just clean up our code before we
leave from this lesson yeah
so far in this course you have learned
about only one way of putting a bunch of
values together and that is the arrays
but arrays have some limitation and the
biggest one of them is the fact that you
cannot resize an array the only way to
make an area larger or smaller than it
already is to copy it and change its
length during the copy but there is
another type and error list which is
like a dynamic array you can create an
arraylist you can put item in it or you
can take away items from it and it will
also adjust its length depending on how
many elements it's holding
now to use an error list in your code
you will have to first import the error
list class to do so you will have to
write import
java.util Dot
errorist
then
to create an array list you will have to
write
array list
then you will have to put a less than
sign and inside you will have to write
the type of the data you want to store
in this array list
now I know so far you have been only
seeing int and this is the first time
you are seeing something called an
integer used as a type I will explain
what this is but let's just keep on
typing and finish creating our new error
list okay so error list integer then
name of the error list which in this
case will be number
equals
new
error list
integer
that's it we now have an empty error
list of integers
I forgot the is there
now what's this integer class here
I have taught you that data types such
as int
or double or float
Boolean these are all primitive types
but in Java you can also make them as
reference types using the wrapper
classes
so this integer class share integer is
actually a wrapper class
for the Primitive type INT in other
words
integer is the reference type form of
the regular inch type so just like
integer you also have double
float Boolean and so on
and when you are creating an array list
you cannot use the Primitive in type you
have to use the integer wrapper class
I hope that makes sense
since we have an in the error list in
our hand let's put some item in it
now to insert a new item in an error
list you cannot just use the old Curly
braces syntax rather you will have to
use the add method
in this way you will have to write
numbers then dot add
then the value that you are trying to
add which in this case will be one
and a semicolon
you can make a bunch of copies of this
line and just
add other numbers as well
there you go
now to print out an error list to the
console you will have to write system
dot out Dot println
numbers which is the name of our error
list in this case then Dot
to a string
now the two string is a method that is
present in every single reference type
in Java and later on when you will learn
about object oriented programming you
will also learn about creating your own
twisting methods within your custom
classes
for now just remember that to print out
an error list you will have to write out
the name of the error list first and
then the method to history
let's run the code and see if it runs
fine or not
so as you can see the error list looks
like an array in the console
now you can also print out a single
value
from the arraylist if you want to
but for that you will have to use
the get method so you'll subdoc then get
then the git method actually takes an
integer
which will be the index of the value you
are trying to print
like arrays error listers are also zero
based so the first index of an error
list will always be zero
so the index of one in this case is 0
to 1. 2
three and four so if you want to print
out three on the console you will have
to send numbers dot get and then two
here
let's run the code
beautiful we have three printed out on
the console
I have already said that analysts are
Dynamic so you can add as many elements
as you want using the add method and you
can also remove elements from an error
list
so if you say numbers
dot remove
and it will take a number which will be
the index of the element you are trying
to delete so if you want to remove 3
from our error list we will say numbers
dot remove and pass2
then let's print out the entire error
list and see if she exists or not
question
okay
let's run the code
yeah three has been successfully removed
but you can also remove items by value
so for example if I want to get rid of 4
I can do so but
instead of passing and primitive 4 if
you write 4 here this will be a
primitive integer Type 4 it will work as
an index but if you pass
a reference Type 4 like this integer
dot value of
and then pass the Primitive type which
in this case is 4
and if we run the code
you will see that we have successfully
removed four from our error list now an
error list can store anything starting
from integers booleans characters
strings and your custom class objects
anything that you can think of we will
work with much more complex at least
in later lessons for now just let's get
hang of the basics okay now you can also
remove all the items from an error list
by saying the name of the earliest Dot
clear
this will clear out the entire error
list and make it empty
there you go so I have already showed
you how you can add new items to an
error list how you can get them remove
them clear an entire analyst now let me
show you how you can update an element
inside an error list
for that there is the set method
so you will type out the name of the
error list then Dot
and is a set
and you will have to put an index here
so again let's update
the 3 here and its index is 2 we'll put
2 here comma then you will have to put
the value that you want to replace three
with
and since the the error list is of
reference types you will have to use the
integer Dot
value of method once again and we will
say 30 so we will replace
3 with 30. let's run the code and see
what happens
excellent it it works out just fine
so like an array you can also sort your
array list
right now we have added the numbers in a
sequential order here but
if we randomize them like for example if
we put five
at the top then one after three
then two at the end
okay let's get rid of this indices
because
now these are getting
misleading
okay let's run the code and see what
happens
so as you can see the numbers are all
jumbled around now to sort this error
list you will have to write the name of
the arraylist the DOT
and then
sort
in the method now you can see that there
is a small squiggly line under the sort
method name and this is because the sort
method will actually take a parameter
which is known as a comparator okay so
as you can see it says comparator in the
parameter list
let me explain what this is first let's
import the comparator class so it's a
import
Java
dot util
Dot comparator
and then inside the sort method we will
say
comparator dot natural
order which which is a method inside the
comparator class
and what we are saying is that sort this
error list in its natural order okay
let's run the code and see if it works
or not
yeah it works just fine we have
successfully sorted our error list now
you can also reverse the order of this
error list by saying
compared to Dot
reverse order
which is similar to Natural order but
this time all the values will be sorted
in a reverse manner
there you go we have five four three two
one liftoff now three very small but
useful methods that the allergies have
is the size method the contains method
and the intimator
first let's see what the size method
does so if you ever want to know how
many elements are there inside an error
list you can just say the name of the
error list and then
size
now this size method will return an
integer after counting all the elements
in the error list you can also check
whether an error list contains a certain
value or not and to do that you will
have to write contains and since
these are all reference type numbers
we'll have to use the integer Dot
value of method and we will have to put
for example one let's check if the error
list contains one or not
see it says true which means it contains
one and if we put 10 here the output
should be false
and yes it does
now there is another method that checks
whether an error list contains anything
at all or not and it's
the
is
empty method
and since our analyst here actually
contains some elements the output should
be false
and yes it is but if we clear our list
just be before checking for emptiness we
will see
yeah it says true
now the final thing that I would like to
show you is the for each Loop
now you have learned about the for Loop
already in a previous lesson and you
know that you can use it to Loop over
regular arrays
but when it comes to an arraylist there
is another kind of loop let me show you
how it works now keep in mind the forage
Loop looks and works a lot differently
than the for Loops but I'll try my best
to explain them as lucidly as I can
foreign
list that you want to Loop over such as
numbers and then
for each
then here it says action what you will
say is
number
then you will make an arrow like this
and then a set of curly braces
now inside the set of curly braces you
will say something like system
Dot out
dot print Ln
and let's multiply each number with two
just as an example so you'll send number
into two
and in our line
now let's also print out the entire
arraylist at the end so numbers dot to
string
yeah let's run the code for now and then
I will explain what's happening inside
the for each Loop
run
so as you can see we have successfully
multiplied each value in this error list
and we have also printed out the
original arraylist here now let me
explain the forage Loop for you so when
you are saying numbers dot for each
number you are saying that for each
number in the numbers arraylist
you want to perform the actions within
this set of curly braces or within this
block of code
so imagine this Arrow like we are
ordering the compiler like for each
number perform this action that I am
pointing towards
now technically it's called a Lambda
expression it's it's like a method that
doesn't have any name
now of course I'm over simplifying stuff
here but for now this is enough to
understand now as you can see that
although you are multiplying each value
of the numbers I released we do inside
the forage Loop body the original error
list remains unchanged
now let's just for practice uh update
the original error list and replace each
value with their multiplied counterparts
okay
now to do that what we can do is
let's first print out the original
error list we will say
uh B4
and plus yeah we are going to use the
plus sign once again in this case
because it's a simple program
and then we will take this out and we
will say after
plus and then
number start doing string okay now
inside the for each Loop what we want to
do is we want to say
numbers
dot set and inside the set of
parentheses we will say numbers Dot
index of which is another method that
can return the index of a given value so
will bus number here
comma number
into two
so you are essentially
using the index of method to get the
index of the current value of the number
variable and then we are updating its
element with the multiplied value okay
let's get rid of the println call here
and let's keep our fingers crossed and
try to run the program
yeah seems like it has worked out we
have successfully overwritten all the
values of the error list with their
multiplied counterparts now this is one
of the many fun programs that you can
write to practice your skills I would
suggest that you go around the internet
find interesting problems that feels
challenging to you and solve them to
flex those Java muscles okay
now that you have learned about air
release let me show you another kind of
collection that's pretty common and
pretty useful in some scenarios these
are called hash Maps now hash maps are
actually key value Pairs and if you want
to compare it python then python
dictionaries are kind of similar to Hash
Maps
now to work with hash Maps first you
will have to import the hashmap class
to do so you will just write import
java.util Dot hashmap
let's get rid of all the early code and
start working on hashmap okay
Now to create a new hash map in Java you
will have to write hash map
and then just like the add list you will
have to first put the type of the key
so in my case I am making a hash map
where I'll be storing the scores for my
different subjects maybe at my school or
summer
so the key will be string
and the value will be the scores of the
subject so maybe English 98 maths 85 and
so on so this will be integers
and then I will name the hash map
something maybe uh
exams course
equals to new
hash map
string integer
that's it
we have successfully created an empty
hash map and since I have already
discussed
these wrapper classes in a previous
lesson I will not repeat
now to put something in this new hash
map you can use the put method
so exams course
dot put
and first we will need to put the name
of the subject so it will be a string
and
maybe a math
and then a comma and then this course
I'm not that good at math so maybe 75
then we will say exam
scores
dot put
another subject may be a sociology
and 85
exams scores dot put English
95 and so on
now to print out a hash map to the
console you can say system dot out Dot
println
exam discourse dot to string just like
you did with the error list
okay let's run the code and see if
everything works or not run
excellent the hash map prints out
uh so my score for English is 95
sociology 85 and math 75. uh I hope you
have already guessed that the item you
are putting into the hash map is not
sorted so even though I have put math at
first it comes out in the end so if I
put some more subjects
foreign
and let's see
what ordered this show up in the console
see as they're actually showing up in
random order but that's how hash maps
are you don't have to worry about them
now you can also print out a single
value from a hash map to do so you will
have to write
the name of the hash map then a DOT and
get
then you will have to pass a key in our
case the keys are all strings so I will
write
let's get the score for
English
run
and yeah we are getting the score of
English now apart from the put method
there is also another method put if
absent that first checks if a value
already exists in the hash map or not
and if it doesn't then it will put it
otherwise it will just skip it now you
can
write exam scores Dot
put if absent
and let's try out with math
math and let's put a new value here
maybe 70.
and then I would print out the entire
hash map here
string
nice
so as you can see the value of math is
still 75 even though I have tried to put
a new value for it but since the put if
absent method actually checks whether
math already exists or not in the hash
map it didn't override the original
value now if you want to replace one of
the values however you can use the
replace method
and it will take a key in this case we
are still working with math and we are
updating its value from 75 to 70. what a
shame
so as you can see the value of math has
been changed to 70. now just like the
put if absent method there is another
method called get or default
for example
if I try to get
a key that doesn't exist let's say for
example religion
we know that it doesn't exist in our
hash map let's see what the output is
as you can see it says null but if we
say get or default
and we give it a default value of 0.
or maybe -1
and run the code
so the program will return -1 if the
given key is not bound
now like an error list you can clear a
hash map by saying
exams course
Dot
clear
and this should clear out the entire
hash map
there you go and now if you want to
check the number of elements that exist
on the hash map you can do so by saying
the name of the hashmap dot size
this will return an integer after
counting all the elements present in the
hash map right now which is 0 because we
have just cleared it out
but if we get rid of that line it should
be back to five
excellent to remove an item from the
hash map you can use the remove method
like this exam scores dot remove and
then you should put a name of this one
of these keys so let's get rid of
sociology
and I'll put it here semicolon then exam
score start to be string
let's run the code
as you can see sociology is not present
here now you may also want to check
whether a certain item exists on the
hatch map or not and you can do that in
two OS
either you can check for a key
or you can check for a value for example
if I want to check if the math key
exists or no I can do so by saying the
name of the hashmap exam scores dot
contains
key and then the key I want to check
against which is math in the this case
and it comes out as true
now if I want to check if I have this
code 100 in any of the subjects or not I
can do so by saying examscores Dot
contains
value and then the value I'm looking for
which in this case is 100.
now you can also put a reference type
100 here if you want to do that
the value of and
it shouldn't make any difference
yeah it just works and I have also
taught you that in case of at least when
you are trying to update one of the
values you need to pass the integer as
in reference type you can actually pass
a primitive type as well the set method
will convert it to a reference type
automatically but it's up to you what
you would like to do and what you want
finally you can check if a hash map is
empty or Not by using
the name of the hash map which is
examsforce Dot
is empty and since our hashmap is not
indeed this should return false
yeah it returns as false
cache Maps also have for each Loop just
like arraylist and now I will show you
an example of using them with hashmaps
to do so first you will need to write
out the name of the hashmap which is the
exams course in this case then you will
set Dot
for each
just like at least you will create a new
Lambda method here but in this case it
will say
the key
comma the value then the arrow and
the curly braces now the key here is the
subject and the value
is this Force so I'll just do it like
this
and then system dot out dot print Ln
name of the subject
Plus
Dash plus the associated score let's put
a semicolon at the end
get rid of these empty call
and see if it works or not okay I just
noticed that there is a small squiggly
line here that's because I didn't
enclose the two variables within a set
of parentheses here
in case of an error list we had only one
variable so it didn't need this
parenthesis but since we have multiple
variables here subject and score we will
need a set of parentheses around them
let's run the code and see if it works
or not
okay seems like it works now what we are
going to do we will Loop over the entire
hash map just like we did in case of the
error list and we will update the value
of each subject score just for the
purpose of practice now to do that
we already have the name of the subject
which is the key and we also have the
value which is the score
to update the values we will say exam
score start replace you have already
learned about this then we will subject
which is the key and then we will take
away 10.
from each subject maybe for bad behavior
or something
then we will say system dot out Dot
println
and exam scores dot blue string
okay I hope everything works out fine
and I cannot spot any mistakes let's hit
the Run button
yeah so I have indeed taken out 10 from
each subject so English was 95 and now
it's 85 Bengali was 100 and now it's 90
sociology is 75 from 85 computer
programming has become 90 from 100 and
finally math has become 65 from 75.
again I would suggest that you go into
the internet looking for problems that
you can solve to just practice all the
things you are learning in this course
this will really make you confident in
Java now that you have learned most of
the basics of java it's time that we
start discussing about object oriented
programming now the concept of
object-oriented programming in itself is
really huge and to be very honest you
cannot learn how to make good
object-oriented programs from a course
or a book what I can do is I can teach
you the basic concepts around
object-oriented programming
and once you have learned them you will
have to learn the rest from experience
by making larger and larger software
following good practices and so on
now at a higher level object-oriented
programming is about modeling your
software around real life objects for
example maybe we can build a book
borrowing system where a user can come
register and login check for a book's
availability borrow it if it's available
and they can also return it on time they
can also check the list of the books
they have borrowed so far now in this
aforementioned system there can be two
objects one the user and two the book
we can store information such as the
user's name and birthday and in case of
a book we can store the book's title and
maybe the name of its authors and so on
so let's begin by creating a user class
in our software and as we keep working
on this simple program we will learn
about the different concepts around
object-oriented programming so first
open up the files menu by clicking on
the file icon here and
click on the add file button name your
new file user Dot
Java in this file you will need to
create a new class like we have done
with the hello world file so write
public class
user now we are declaring this class as
public because we want this class to be
available within our entire program
now inside the class we will store the
user's name which can be string so
public
string name
and we will also store the user's date
of birth
so we will say public
local date which is a reference type for
storing dates in Java
and we'll say birthday
now to use the local Red class within
our user class we will have to first
import it so import Java dot time dot
local date
uh by the way do not get intimidated
about the amount of classes that Java
has built into it as you will keep
working with Java for months or maybe
for years you will eventually learn
about a lot of them
now we have a new user class let's go
back to our hello world class and create
a new user object now creating a custom
object like a user object is not very
different from creating a string
so you will have to write user which
will be the type of our object
then you will have to name the object
maybe let's name it younger user because
we will have a older user as well later
on
equals new
user and a set of parentheses now we
have a user but this user at its current
state doesn't have any name or date of
birth
since these variables are declared in
the class level of the user class this
will be initialized as null by default
so they will get default values
now variables like these at a class
level are called properties
and since these properties are tagged as
public we can actually access them from
outside of the user class and give some
value to them
so we will say
younger user dot name equals
[Music]
Farhan hasin Junior
excellent then younger
user Dot
birth J equals
local date Dot
purse and inside the purse method we
will pass
1995
0 1
31 which means 31st January 1995.
now the local date.burst method can pass
a date from a given string and convert
it to local date type again for using
the local date class here we will have
to first import it so import Java dot
time dot local dates then we would also
like to print something out on the
screen and for that we'll say system dot
out Dot printf
and inside the printf method
we will say that modulus
s was born back in modulus s
then after the comma we will replace the
first format specifier here with the
names so we will say younger user
dot name
and then after that we would like to
replace the second format specified with
the birthday
but since the birthday is not a string
you will have to first convert deep
string by calling the twisting method
and I have already said that the
twisting method usually exists in all
the reference types and
any local date object is actually
reference type
let's try running our program and see if
it works or not
so yeah it works just fine Farhan hasin
Junior was warning back in 1995 c131
now I have already said once that using
something called Methods we can actually
Implement some Dynamic behaviors to our
classes
for example since we have the per day of
the user we can use it to calculate
their current age
so we will create a new public method
public because we want this method to be
accessible throughout our entire program
and then we will have to write the
return type of our method which in this
case is integer because age is always an
integer
then we will put the name of the method
which is age
and put a pair of curly braces
now from inside the method we will
calculate the age into H equals
and for that Java actually has a pretty
nifty class
so in import
Java dot time dot period
now this period class has some method
that you can use to calculate the
difference between two local date types
so we will say
period
dot between
and inside this method called we will
put a starting date which is the
birthday so we will say this Dot
birthday I will explain this this later
on and then we'll put
local date dot now now this period dot
between method call will actually
calculate the difference between the
user's birthday and our current day and
then we would like to return age dot get
years because we want to return the age
in years okay we do not want anything
else
let's go back to our hello world class
and change this string to something like
was born back in and he is now modulus
is
a module does d ears port
so you say
that user was born back in the birthday
and he is now X years old so we'll put a
comma after the twisting call and say
younger user dot h and we will put a set
of parentheses because this is a method
and you will need to put a set of
parentheses to call any method in Java
let's run the program and see if it
works or not
yeah looks like everything has worked
out just fine it says foreign Junior was
born back in 1995.
0131 and he is now 27 years old
excellent
now what is this blue this keyword here
now to explain this we will actually
need two users so let's create a new
user
user older user
equals new user
and we'll say holder user dot name
equals
senior
and then you will say folder user Dot
birthday equals local date Dot
first
and let's put
1975
0 1
15.
okay now we'll put this system out Dot
printf
at line 10.
and we'll make a copy of it at the end
of our program postponed back in uh okay
all right let's replace younger user
with older user
let's run the code and see what happens
foreign
ERS Engineers born 27 years old and this
is 47 years old nice now
you can see that we have two different
users in our program and both of these
users are actually created from the same
user class
so when we are trying to calculate the
age of the user how would the computer
know which user we are referring or
which date of birth we are referring to
this is where the this keyword comes in
you see we have two instances of the
user cluster and this keyword will refer
to the current object being worked on so
when we are saying younger user dot age
then the value of this will be the
younger user object
and when you are saying older user.h the
value of this would be the older user
object okay so let's
get rid of the extra user here
change the younger user's name to just
user
and let's start working on the book
class
let's go back to the files menu create a
new file with the name book Dot Java
now let's declare a new class public
Plus
book and for a book we would like to
store
a public
freeing
title and public
history author
yeah that's pretty much it for the book
class now let's go back to the hello
world again
and we will say book
equals to new
book
and then book dot title equals to
carmilla
book dot author equals to
Shelton
let's put a semicolon at the end and now
we have a new book
so how about we implement the
functionality of borrowing books I will
put it in the user class so let's close
this menu as we don't need that
and we will create a new method here
path leak
borrow
and this borrow method will actually
accept a parameter because this method
has to know which book the user is
trying to borrow right
so we will say book so this method is
actually accepting variable of book type
then
let's create arraylist
of type book
let's call it books
equals new array list
and book
closing and we will also have to import
the error list class so import
ant
java.util dot arraylist okay then we can
say
this dot books dot add
and book
so you're adding the book we have
received within the borrow method to our
list of books okay
let's go back to our hello world class
and we will say
user dot borrow
and we will pass the book to it
I think we have made a small mistake
that is we haven't said what kind of
data the borrow method is returning now
as you can see the method actually
returning nothing so we will have to say
for it which means it doesn't return
anything at all there is no return
statement whatsoever it just makes some
changes to the books error list
okay let's go back to hello world and
this looks all right so far let's update
this printf method
yeah and h
okay let's let's write another one
system dot out Dot printf
and it will say modulus s has
borrowed
these books
and with some modulus s okay let's put a
comma here and we will say user dot name
has borrowed
user dot books
dot two string
okay
uh let's also put a new line character
at the end of our printf statements
otherwise they may not look as good as
we want them to be
okay let's run the program and see what
happens then we will go through what
happening in this entire system once
again
foreign
just as I expected so as you can see it
says Farhan has engineer was born back
in 1919 and so on and then it says
Farhan has engineer has borrowed this
book's book at and then a large number
but we are expecting maybe the name of
the book or maybe the name of the author
or something like that right but that
didn't happen let me tell you why
you can see that we have been using the
method to string a lot right by using
the method twisting a lot and I have
already said that this twist string
method
comes with every single reference types
now our book here is a custom class and
whatever book object we are working with
are all reference types
now since we have created the book class
ourselves it doesn't have a built into a
string method that's why we are getting
some random values here
now to solve this problem we will have
to implement a twisting method we can do
that by saying public
string
to string
and then we will return a string
representation of this book like return
string dot format here and we'll say
modulus s by
modulus is then a full stop and after
the comma we will say
this dot title
and this dot author so whenever we are
trying to access one of the properties
within a class from a method within the
same class we can use that this keyword
okay let's try to run the program once
again and see if it solves our issue or
not
let's make our console bigger
foreign
I think that full stop there looks
pretty bad because it's going to show up
like a list of books
let's get rid of that
and also I think this is a good time to
switch back to the Stacked layout once
again since our codes are getting bigger
horizontally and this gives us a better
look at our lights
okay so what have we done so far we have
created two custom classes representing
our users and the books we have created
a new user object we have given him the
ability to borrow books from us we have
also calculated their age using method
we have implemented title and author for
our books and we have also implemented
accustomed to string method so this is
really a lot to be honest but we will do
more now so far we have been declaring
all our methods and our properties as
public but to be very honest this is not
something you should be doing a lot
let's learn about something called a
Constructor
as you can see when you are trying to
create a new user you are saying user
then name of the user object equals new
and then you are writing the name of the
class once again and then a set of
parentheses as if you are trying to call
a method called user
well that's kind of true
every single class that we have in Java
has a special method called Constructor
this method is responsible for
initializing all the properties with
their default values so what we can do
is we can customize these Constructor
method and make it do things
let's start by writing a Constructor for
our user class okay
we will say
user and will not write anything like
public or maybe some sort of return type
nothing at all we will just start by
writing what the name of the class is
then we will put a set of parentheses
and set of curly braces so this is our
Constructor method now let's think about
what we want from the user when they are
creating a new user object right
we want their name so we will receive or
ask for their name and we will also ask
for their birthday
now this birthday
can be taken as a local date but we will
take it as a string
I will tell you why
but
now inside this Constructor method we
will say
this dot name equals name
and this Dot
birthday equals local date dot purse
birthday
so what we are doing essentially is we
are asking the user for a name and we
are storing that name in the name
variable or name property within the
user class then we are also asking for a
birthday and we are storing that
birthday in the birthday property but
since the birthday property is of type
local date we will have to purse the
birthday from a string format to local
date format now let's go back to our
hello world class and make the necessary
changes here we will say user equals
user and we will put the name
inside this Constructor call and we'll
put a comma here and we'll also put the
birthday
within the Constructor call because now
the user class is capable of accepting
these two values let's run the code and
see if everything works just as before
or not
seems like I have made a small typo here
the D should have been capital
foreign
just like before
now
since we can initialize the user with a
name and a date of birth right at the
creation process
we can actually make the name and
birthday private
which means we can no longer do things
like
user dot birthday or user dot name
but we still need to know the user's
name and user part derived
for that we have something called
getters
so we will create a new method
somewhere in this user class public
get name
and the return type B string
and we will say return this dot name
and we will also say public string get
birthday
and you will say return this dot
birthday dot to string
now let's go back to the hello world
class and make use of these two Getters
we will come down to printf and we will
say user dot get name
how do you say
user dot get
birthday and we'll get rid of the two
string calls since the birthday will
come back as a string by default
now let's run the code and see how it
works
okay we also have to replace this name
here and as you can see since we have
made the name properties private the
hello world class actually fails to
access the user's name which is a good
thing
I will explain why let's just make it
working again
so yeah it's it's back to normal now
since
the name and birthday properties have
become private no one can change their
values from outside the user class
which means these are now much more
secret than they were before another
thing that is now we can pass the name
of the user
and the birthday as a strings the hello
world class has no business in knowing
what is the actual type of the birthday
is
all the Hello World Class needs to know
that if it passes a user name and a
birthday in string format a new user
will be creative
this is called abstraction
so what we are doing is we are hiding
the complexities of the user class
behind this beautiful looking Gator
methods Constructor methods you can
already see how cleaner the user object
creation looks compared to the book
object creations
let's make the same changes to the book
class as well so we will go back to it
and change the title
and author to private
then we will Implement to getter methods
so public
get title
return this title the return type will
be string
and then we will say public
a string
get author and we say return this Dot
author
Etc
let's also implement the Constructor so
we will say book
we will take the title as a string and
then we will take the author name as a
string
then we will set this dot title equals
title
and this dot author
equals author
nice
let's update the creation process so we
will pass the title of the book and the
name of the author
with the new keyword and get rid of that
excellent the program already looks much
cleaner now another thing that I would
like to change is I would like to make
the books list private and Implement a
getter for that as well so let's go back
to the user class and let's say
foreign
public
and this time we will be returning
string
borrowed books
and we'll say return peace dot books dot
history
excellent
now the hello world class doesn't know
about the complexities of the books list
either we'll just say
borrowed volts
did I meet it private yet no I didn't so
we will make it private
okay let's see if the program works just
as before or not
excellent the program works just as
before
now I hope you can already see the
beauty of object rendered programming
and how cleaner the program actually
looks in reality
we still have to learn a few more
Concepts around object entry programming
such as inheritance now assume that our
book borrowing system has multiple types
of booths there can be the regular books
I mean the hardcover ones or the printed
ones then there can be ebooks and there
can be audio books now although they
have some similarities they also have
some differences such as
the ebooks and the regular books have
page counts where the audio books have
run times
also the ebooks have formats such as PDF
or ePub or so on so trying to implement
different kinds of books using the same
class can be cumbersome
now you may think that you will make
copies of the book class and add or
remove the necessary properties methods
to them but that's not a very good idea
this is why inheritance comes in
so we can make a default book class with
the most common properties and methods
in it and then we can make
child book classes that will inherit all
the properties and methods from the
parent book class and we can also add
some new properties and methods to them
let's see an example first we will add
the page count property to the book so
we will say private
int page count
and for that we will have to pass
the page count to the Constructor here
so we'll set this Dot Page count equals
page count
we'll go back to our hello world class
and we will say
I don't remember the actual page count
of the book but let's put 270.
nice everything should be normal let's
run that code and make sure
ah that was a silly mistake I didn't
accept the parameter here
let's run the program and make sure
excellent
now we will create a new audio book
class
audio book Dot
Java
yes
and we will say public
class audio book
extends
book now since we are declaring this
audiobook class as an extension of the
parent book class it already has
all these properties and methods we have
described here
so what we need to add is a runtime so
it's a private int
front
so runtime means
how long these audio books run so the
runtime will be in minutes
then we will have to create
a new Constructor here so we'll say
audio book
just like before and we will accept the
runtime
so it's a int
runtime
and then inside the pair of curly braces
we will say
this Dot
runtime
equals
runtime now here is a problem I have
already said that since this audiobook
class is an extension of the book class
it also inherits all these private
properties which means we will still
have to fill them up somehow
but the audiobook Constructor
doesn't accept any of these values
okay let's see what we can do to solve
this first we'll copy all these
parameters from the book Constructor
and add them to the audiobook
Constructor
one of the problems have been solved we
are now accepting all the necessary
information for the parent book class
now we will say super
and we will pass title
author and pitch count
now the super keyword here actually
refers to the parent class of our
current class so when you are calling
the method super we are actually calling
the Constructor of the parent book class
so we have successfully filled up all
the necessary properties of the parent
class as well let's try out by creating
a new audiobook
let's go back to the hello world class
and after book
we will say
audiobook
equals
new audio book
and we will say Dracula
foreign
stalker
and the page count
actually we do not have to pass the page
count here we can modify our Constructor
a little bit we do not need to accept
the page counter
instead we can pass 0 as the page count
yeah that would be better and we can
just accept the runtime
so for example maybe the Dracula book
would run for 30 000 minutes so I put 30
thousands here
audiobook see I have made a mistake
and I think we should
start naming our books so carmilla
[Music]
okay so we have successfully created a
new audio book here just for the sake of
our codes Clarity let's get rid of all
the code that we do not need so we will
get rid of
the user dot borrow call we have seen
examples of that we will also get rid of
the system.out.printf calls we will get
rid of the user as well because for now
we will be focusing strictly on books
audio books and ebooks
so let's create a new
system.out.printf method here
we will say
sorry
Dracula dot two string
[Music]
because remember that the audiobook
class already inherits the two string
method from the book class
okay let's print out something on the
screen so it's a system dot out dot
print
Ln
and Dracula dot Google string
let's run the code and see if it works
or not
yeah it works just fine okay now that we
have a audiobook class let's create a
new class called ebook
chef
okay King public
class
ebook extends
and then within the set of curly braces
uh actually we can copy a bunch of code
from here let's
copy everything to the ebook class
and we will say
private is string
format
and then we will accept
everything and we will also accept the
page count this time because ebooks have
page count okay
so input page account and then we will
also accept the format so we'll say
string format
this dot format equals one CF
nice uh yeah everything looks fine okay
we have to change this to ebook
let's go back to hello world and try to
create a new ebook Okay so ebook
so Jeeves I will create a Chiefs book
new
ebook
carry
on Chiefs
written by PG
old house I hope I'm spelling his name
correctly
then the page count would be 280 I guess
and finally the format will be PDF
let's put a semicolon there and let's
see if the book has been created
properly or not so Jeep stop to stream
okay so carry on Jeeps by PG Port house
so we have successfully created
different kinds of books based on a
parent class
now this is what I had in store for this
course in terms of object oriented
programming I have taught you what are
classes what are objects water
properties and methods Constructor
methods and you have also learned about
inheritance
now there are a lot of things that you
will have to still learn like method
overloading and overriding Abstract
method and whatnot but I would not like
to overwhelm you with all these Concepts
in a single course
what I would suggest that try to
understand everything that I have taught
you in this course uh as thoroughly as
you can and then keep practicing make
programs make bigger programs and try to
understand whatever concept seems
complex to you and as you keep working
with Java as you keep making more and
more fun projects you will start to
understand a lot of the complex Concepts
around object oriented programming and
whatnot
so I hope you have learned something
good from this course and maybe someday
I will see you in another course as well
so till then stay safe and take care